pela primeira vez na história da
humanidade a gente está conseguindo
fazer com que inteligência vire comodity
Porque até então a inteligência ela era
apenas um produto biológico através do
nosso Gene então era uma questão de
sorte tu tu nascer mais inteligente ou
tu tem mais habilidade ou tu ter nascido
num ambiente onde pessoas os seus pais
se incentivaram para isso então
ambiência e biologia né DNA e ambiência
que tu foi exposto hoje em dia não Por
mais que ten uma ambiência pobre e um
DNA pobre ou seja tu nasceu burro tu tem
uma inteligência que hoje tem um QI
equivalente é um gênio porque vários
testes que eu mesmo fiz com teste de q
no ch pt4 Turbo ele retornou ele
conseguiu resolver problemas até 155 de
k hum problemas matemáticos foi até 130
e poucos então o mesmo o GPT 3.5 que é
mais burrinho ele chegou em teste GQ ele
até 120 130 se a gente vai considerar
que o k méo do brasileiro é 83 nos dias
de hoje tu ter 155 deqi que é um k
equivalente a do Elon musk a tua
disposição 24 horas por dia faz com que
tu tenha uma amplificação sem dúvida só
que as pessoas não sabem nem usar isso
Uhum E esse é o problema que a gente
enfrenta hoje a a inteligência ela tá
disponível é como se fosse assim o
óculos ele tá disponível e digamos que
tu tem um problema de visão tu bota um
óculos tu resolve esse problema de visão
uhum só que daí Digamos que a gente tem
um monte de óculos disponível para todo
mundo por preços extremamente acessíveis
só que ninguém sabe que precisa de um
óculos todo mundo acha que cara mas eu
nasci assim eu enxergo tudo borrado
mesmo é e daí as pessoas não vem que se
ela botasse um alcos resolveria tudo que
é tu fazer tu utilizar inteligência
artificial para amplificar tuas
capacidades cognitivas atuais e por
exemplo assim eu tô no game de agora e
já um ano e um ano e pouquinho esse game
tem é um existe um um Hype muito grande
em torno do dia então do nada tem hoje a
gente tem um monte de especialista em a
O copyrighter que era que não deu certo
com copywriter pum virou especialista em
a o cara de tráfego não consegue mais
fazer tráfego virou especialista em a o
cara que era social mídia daí assim vai
até tá a mina da Dan do tiktok virou
especialista em a nossa E por quê Porque
tá no Hype Só que essa galera vai perder
esse Hype porque a ia vai perder um Hype
ela não vai perder a utilidade nem
perder o impacto que ela vai ter no
mundo mas ela vai perder o Hype e essa
galera vai deixar de existir e eu vou
continuar falando eles vão no curto
prazo inclusive vão fazer muito mais
dinheiro que eu porque eles promete um
monte de coisa eu não prometo nada eu
falo que eu vou ensinar os fundamentos
sim mas no longo prazo eu vou permanecer
enquanto eles vão ficar Uhum Então
quando tu pensa já no longo isso é outra
coisa também tipo quando tu pensa assim
ó vou permanecer no jogo por mais tempo
tu começa a pensar no longo prazo e aqui
que eu acho que tem um erro muito grande
da galera que quer escalar os negócios e
tal que é só pensando no curto prazo né
só eu acredito que existe como juntar as
duas coisas não nem sempre exige
maturidade se tu tá sem grana agora cara
investe realmente no cash Flow faz a
grana queem O Jão falou aqui mas eu acho
que começa a pensar assim se não tem
alguma coisinha que tu pode fazer no teu
negócio para que tu possa expandir ele
pensando no longo prazo principalmente
porque o que que acontece
na nossa época lá em 2018 né porque tipo
no Mark digital a gente tinha
praticamente dinossauros já uhum para
crescer isso era muito difícil por quê a
gente precisava ter times grandes e
times grandes são difíceis de gerenciar
é muito investimento de tempo hoje em
dia com o ia tu consegue ter times no
comecinho da que antes da gente começar
nosso podcast eu comentei contigo sobre
agentes e tu pensou assim não esse
negócio me complicado nem sei o que que
é vou falar outra coisa aqui a gente
falou segundo cérebro Mas uma coisa que
eu tô muito focado é em a criação de
agentes o que que é um agente o agente é
algo que tem uma agência o que que é o
que que é ter uma agência por exemplo tu
é alguém que tem uma Tu tem uma agência
que que é agência a capacidade de tomar
decisões com base em parâmetros em base
naquilo que acontece então o que que é o
agente ele é uma inteligência artificial
que não não só executa comandos Ele toma
decisões e executa comandos com base
naquilo que ele tá
percebendo ele tem agência ele consegue
tu dar uma missão para ele ele vai fazer
aquilo Uhum Então ele vai recrutar
outros agentes ele vai pegar e fazer as
coisas acontecerem ele vai tomar
decisões ali para chegar naquele naquela
meta que tu botou para ele então ele não
vai simplesmente por exemplo como
funciona um chat GPT da vida né um um
que é um GPT que é ele é baseado numa
tecnologia de transformer que é um
basicamente ele pega textos inputs e
joga naquilo que é uma rede neural que
basicamente eh O que que é uma rede
neural ela é uma rede artificial baseada
na rede sináptica humana então o teu
cérebro Ele eles são bilhões de
neurônios que se conectam através de uma
rede elétrica onde constrói fluxos de
caminhos que na rede neural da i são os
parâmetros e tu é o que faz tu pensar do
jeito que tu pensa Então teve um cara
que se chama e George griff esse cara
ele durante 30 anos foi ridicularizado
pelos cientistas porque ele falava que
queria criar uma rede neural uma coisa
que imitasse o cérebro no computador só
que eventualmente esse cara conseguiu
fazer isso Hum então o pessoal fala de a
como fosse algo novo mas nos anos 40
essa rede neural já tinha papers que
falavam sobre ela antigo eu lembro disso
então assim só que na época parece que
não tinha processamento né não tinha
poder capitacion por exemplo assim o o
ontem Saiu um vídeo
do oficializando que a meta virou metai
entre aspas porque tipo assim a meta que
era o Facebook virou meta porque tava
investido em óculos como esse aqui
óculos de inteligência oficial etc e
eles meio que deram com a cara na parede
né E ontem através de um vídeo do zurk
que ele fez Tipo na casa del era do
metavers n umas coisas assim metaverso
etc eh ele realmente eles entraram agora
de cabeça o foco da meta é ia 100% 100%
ia e eles vão usar isso aqui os óculos
deles como um mecanismo periférico para
utilização da ia tanto que esse óculos
aqui eu tenho um ia nele Posso fazer
perguntas depois a gente pode até te
mostrar ele mas o que acontece né ontem
o zuk fez um vídeo ali e falou o
seguinte eu acho que
ai tem que ser algo para todas as
pessoas e por isso o LMA 3 já está sendo
treinado ele já tem um lema do eles
gastaram 2 milhões de dólares para
treinar milhões ou B milhões 2 milhões
de dólares para treinar o lama 2 e
pegaram e disponibilizaram de graça o
Lhama 2 de graça 2 milhões tu baixa no
teu computador de graça tu pode rodar no
teu computador aí Hum e o que que é esse
essa Lhama né são dois arquiv minhos é
um arquivo de parâmetros que tem 140 GB
e um arquivo em C que tem 500 linhas de
código só só isso roda i é incrível
Nossa mas aí que acontece por que que eu
estudo os fundamentos porque quando eu
sei como esse negócio funciona eu
consigo V fazer ela funcionar da forma
como eu quero então por exemplo eu tenho
certeza que tu já deve ter passado por
isso e a galera que tá nos escutando já
passou por isso que é o quê tu vai chega
no chat PT digita o que tu quer e ele te
dá uma resposta muito ruim já aconteceu
contigo pediu uma hó aconteceu tipo hoje
todo dia todo dia mas é por que tá
acontecendo vamos vamos lá então tu tem
que saber falar a língua do chat entre
aspas porque ah não mas não é português
sim até tem
uma alguns grandes especialistas de I
falam que a nova o novo idioma de
programa informação éem inglês tu vai
ter respostas melhores em inglês E tu
também vai ter uma economia de tokens em
inglês porque na no português a gente
tem a gente tem muita conjugações muitas
preposições muitas coisas que no inglês
é mais direto então quando tu vai a
gente vai falar de token que é essa essa
memória da ia ela vai conseguir de
responder muito mais coisas em inglês do
que em português porque se eu já
comparei quando tu cria um prompt em
português ou inglês o prompt inglês ele
é 30% mais eficiente de de quantidade de
tokens ou seja ele é 30% menor em número
de texto de caracteres então para
começar ali tu já vai ter mais
eficiência porque tu pode botar mais
informação e menos espaço de tempo só
que agora tem outra questão que é o
seguinte essas eas elas são basicamente
treinadas em todo o corpo de
conhecimento que existe na internet por
exemplo o o o lama 2 ele foi treinado
com 10 tb de de textos da Inter
extraídos da internet foi treinado
durante de textos cois foi treinado
durante 8 dias então foi foi não foi 12
foi foi 8 dias treinar durante 8 dias
isso é relativ ente pouco não então não
é 10 Tab é porque sei lá parece é muito
rápido assim 12 dias porque mas era
muitos servidores Hum entendeu se tu for
treinar isso no teu computador eh um
cara fez a conta duraria seria acho que
1.2 milhões de anos se não me engano
computador normal sabe XP normal mas
olha só por isso que a gente vai chegar
aqui no nesse ponto do por o inglês
porque assim foi treinado ess servidores
eles gastaram 2 milhões de servidor de
custo de servidor para treinar isso o o
que que é que anunciou agora que ele
comprou
300.000 gpus da NVidia da NVidia pega o
moleque tá forte esse aí roda qualquer
coisa esse aí esse aí vai vai rodar GTA
6 no máximo jar um CSZ
aqui e tu por que que por que ele
comprou 300.000 gpus isso daí agora sim
o investimento foi maior só em gpus o
investimento dele foi de 10 Bilhões de
Dólares [__] tem mais aí os o custo
de servidor isso são gpus são só gpus E
por que que ele não comprou cpus né que
ele tá comprando gpus ele não tá
comprando aquele porque olha que loucura
né a o videogame ele roda o quê gráfico
roda gráfico é matriz a i ela funciona
com base em bancos vetoriais em matrizes
então A Iá roda em cima de placa de
vídeo de videogame sabe é isso é muito
doida a Nvidia tá tando uma empresa tipo
ultra ultra [__] aí é por causa dessas
paradas aí né paradas isso é muito doido
então assim ah mas o que que isso tem a
ver com a qualidade do que eu tô falando
aqui da escrever em inglês porque eles
foram treinados em 10 trilhões de de de
10 tb de textos a maioria do textos são
inglês e a funciona com base em contexto
Porque no momento que como é que ela é
treinada ela vai pegando parâmetros ah
sei lá cachorro tem quatro pata cachorro
tem quatro Pat ela vai de vez em quando
vê um cachorro lá Perneta que tem três
patas mas em grande maioria cachorro tem
quatro patas Então ela cria esse
parâmetro esse padrão então ela o o lama
por exemplo ele tem 70 bilhões de
parâmetros então o chat vpt tem quantos
tu sabe olha o
3.5 tem ele não tem nem 100 bilhões de
parâmetros o 4 já tem muito mais que
isso e por que que o o o a o zuk comprou
agora esses 300.000 gpus porque ele tá
treinando o lama 3 que vai ter centenas
e centenas de bilhões de parâmetros mas
mas é o zuk que comprou ou Elon musk não
entendi o eu falei se eu falei Elon musk
eu falei errado foi o zuk Ah foi o zuk
Ah tá eu achei que era o Elon musk não
foi o Mark Z que comprou os tr tr Ah não
sei se foi eu que eu escutei errado mas
enfim [__] pess foi o Zu que comprou
foi o z que comprou e ele e ele botou
realmente ele falou cara a gente vai
entregar isso com código aberto hum ele
quer por que ele ele quer ele quer que
ai esteja aberta ao público open source
ali pra galera é e o que que é o ai já
ouvi falar sobre isso artificial General
intellig ex Mas conta pras pessoas aí é
porque pouca gente sabe disso né eu fico
de cara coisa de nerde mano essa coisa
eu fico de cara que tem cara que se diz
especialista de a eu vi Live esses dias
do cara falando tipo assim ah não e a
não vai substituir emprego e a vai vai
criar muito mais emprego do que tomar
cara tu entendeu o negócio como funciona
porque pela primeira vez na história da
humanidade a gente tem a inteligência
virando commodity não aconteceu isso
antes então a gente não consegue nem
prever o que vai acontecer mas a gente
consegue entender algumas coisas pelo
que já tá acontecendo por exemplo assim
a gente a gente achava que os o a
primeira coisa quando eu imaginava assim
que seria substituído seria um trabalho
manual um trabalho repetitivo manual Eu
também é só que daí os caras vão lá e
cria um negócio que cria imagens
incríveis cria copywriter ali cria
copywriter que tipo assim a a parte
criativa realmente tá sendo substituída
em em grande escala e isso vai ser cada
vez maior Mas tu acha que é substituído
Alan Ou tu acha que é potencializado as
duas coisas por quem é potencializado
substitui quem não é então assim boa de
começo tem muita gente fala assim não e
também aumenta a produção do
potencializado muito é o que faz com que
a demanda seja satisfeita com poucas
pessoas com uma oferta menor exatamente
então por exemplo ontem eu fiz eu deve
tu viu me eu vi que tu vi meus Stories
lá né que eu falei sobre o 4 horas em 4
minutos eu vi alguma coisa sobre isso aí
tipo eu vi mas eu não consumi ass eu
passei Ah tá então 4 horas em 4 minutos
foi o quê Eu dei uma atividade para uma
funcionária minha fazer que é criar um
diagrama de tomar decisão com base numa
reunião que eu dei de duas horas então
ela tinha que escutar fazer um resumo e
criar um diagrama sobre tomada de
decisão ela chegou ela fez o reso ela
escutou fez o resumo chegando no
diagrama ela não conseguiu fazer o
diagrama porque ela não entendia da
ferramenta ela entendia como faz as
coisas daí que que eu fiz eu tinha
reunião no outro dia eu peguei o
transcript do vídeo que a ia tinha feito
joguei no clou aai que é uma ia que tem
200.000 tokens ou seja ela consegue ler
muito mais do que um chat PT que tem
8.000 tokens o chat PT por exemplo 3.5
ele tem 8.000 tokens interessante ISS
então ele só consegue a memória de
trabalho dele entre aspas é só 8.000
então quando ele quando el ele bate 8000
ele reseta por isso que ele esquece o
comando que tu deu lá no começo ô que
raiva é isso cara e eu falo eu falo para
ele [__] irmão eu falei para te fazer a
parada eu falo assim Leia de novo Prom
daí tipo ele não não é ele não consegue
ele não consegue nemar lá então tipo
assim por isso que entendeu o chat PT TR
o quatro agora que que é o quem tem o
assinatura Plus ele tem eles aumentaram
de 16.000 tokens para 32.000 tokens é
por isso que tu consegue ter uma
conversa melhor ali dentro só que o clou
ji ele tem 200.000 tokens é coisa PR
caramba tipo você tu pode literalmente
jogar um livro lá dentro ele vai
conseguir ler o livro inteiro só que não
é só ler o livro inteiro ele é como se
tu lesse o livro inteiro em um segundo
mas tá na tua memória todas as frases
daquele livro instantaneamente o que eu
perguntar sobre aquele livro tu tem na
tua memória e tu fala Então é isso o
clou 200.000 tokens é a tua memória
Nossa que interessante Então assim tá
ali o que que eu fiz eu peguei então
duas horas de conversa joguei no clou Ai
que também é de
graça dei um comando ali para ele para
ele ele é graa ele é de graça mas o que
acontece como no Brasil o lgpd aqui é
muito pesado tipo assim essas regras de
de de dados as empresas de a não estão
vindo PR cá então a gente tu tem que
usar
um criar conta lá Saquei então assim o
que que eu fiz joguei lá mas tem uma
versão premium assim do do desse Cloud
aí Cloud sei lá tem eh ele é é que ele
ele é Claudia que se escreve mas ele é
francês daí tu que sabe falar francês me
falaram assim ah isso aqui tem que falar
cloue é se é Cláudia é é cloue é porque
a o em francês é o os caras são [__] né
M coisa é francês é a mesma coisa a o
cloue é é é francês e tem outro também
que é francês do dessas yas e não que
seja francês ela é da antropic que é uma
empresa que saiu da Open hum a galera
saiu da openai e lançou antropic para
fazer o deles para fazer o deles com
mais contextualização para Business
então o cla ele é pra cop inclusive ele
é ele é muito melhor que sh pt4 hum para
escrever cop Tá aí uma dic PR vocês ó
inclusive ele ainda Vocês conseguem
hackear ele entre aspas eu sei uma coisa
meu passatempo preferido onde eu tava
fazendo isso é hackear ias como é que é
isso isso muito divertido fazer isso
hackar ia hackar ia que é o qu a ia ela
é ela ela funciona com com uma base de
para parâmetros gigantes né tipo assim
de regras Então como só como ela
funciona de uma maneira que nem os
cientistas que criaram elas sabem
exatamente como ela funciona eles sabem
como ela funciona mas eles não conseguem
saber o caminho inteiro que ela fez para
chegar porque são bilhões de nós que
acontecem al no meio desses parâmetros
nós cada como fosse uma simulação de
cada neurônio nosso de forma artificial
que eles não conseguem ver o caminho
inteiro para chegar numa conclusão então
eles não sabem o que tá acontecendo ali
dentro necessariamente por isso que eles
não sabem inclusive Olha que loucura
isso aqui é aquela coisa tipo assim
sensacionalista que é eles não sabem se
a i está consciente já ou não Eles não
sabem uhum porque eles não sabem o que
tá acontecendo nesse cérebro artificial
porque existem comandos que tu dá pr iar
como olha só que loucura isso é um Hack
por exemplo se tu entende daá tu começa
a fazer vários testes e tu começa ela
foi treinada com comportamento humano
então tem muita coisa que tu fala PR ela
que faz com que ela tenha um
comportamento melhor então se tu falar
PR PR ela respirar fundo ela pensa
melhor olha ó se tu falar se tu falar PR
ela que se tu não fizer esse trabalho
bem feito tu vai ser despedido ela
funciona melhor cara que loucura é Eu
acho que eu já fiz uma coisa dessa que
eu falei se tu não responder isso aqui
eu vou morrer sim exatamente então uma
urgência ali no chat tem várias tipo
ontem eu vi um um um um cientista da opi
que é o Greg fazendo ISO ISO pre falou
eu não acredito tipo assim eu não tava
acreditando na comunidade fazendo isso
ele falou assim vou fazer DAE botou uma
carinha de brabo lá na depois no no
Twitch lá que era e [__] funcionou esse
negócio mesmo tipo assim porque ele
botou ess essas regrinhas sabe que o
pessoal descobriu que tu bota várias
coisas dessas e faz aí a performa muito
melhor atualmente assim né po po ser que
eles alterem e tal e e fique diferente
mas por quê Porque ela ela é treinada
com base de conjuntos de coisas humanas
inclusive Por que que ela tem que ter
várias contenções chega até a ser chato
GPT 4 por exemplo que tu vai criar uma
cópia de emagrecimento uma coisa assim
ele fica te impedindo de falar certas
palavras mas por Como ela foi treinada
em base de conhecimento humano a ya se
tornou automaticamente H racista ela se
tornou de xenofóbica por quê Porque ela
foi treinada com base em conhecimento
humano e nós humanos nós somos
xenofóbicos fóbicos racistas E por aí
vai em GD parte então se tu entende dela
Como ela foi treinada Tu sabe como
conversar com ela porque tu sabe como
extrair o máximo dela sim e é por isso
que eu falo dos fundamentos porque assim
eu entendendo ó eu tenho um vídeo de Du
horas lá né e eu não posso jogar isso no
chat PT porque ele tem 32.000 tokens ele
não vai ler tem muito mais coisas ali do
que 32.000 tokens então joguei no Cloud
Ele criou para mim 10 parâmetros que foi
falado sobre mim que eu falei na na
reunião eu peguei e joguei isso num GPT
do chat GPT é outra coisa que são os
gpts que são eh os gpts são chat de gpts
específicos para funções aquele que tu
cria lá que é aquele que tu cria tu sobe
os arquivos e tal então eu peguei cara
depois eu vamos falar disso aí que eu
nunca entendi direito isso aí é eu criei
já vários para mim tipo assim várias
coisas da minha emesa eu já automatizei
com gpts Então o que por isso que eu
comprei aquela conta Empresarial porque
todos os meus funcionários eles têm
acesso a ch GPT e quando eu vejo que
eles estão fazendo uma coisa repetida eu
crio um GPT que ajuda eles nessa coisa
repetida e aumenta a produtividade deles
assim 10x 20x Cara isso é muito poderoso
mano M quero falar sobre isso aí depois
tá se se tu puder compartilhar é muito
poderoso e então eu fiz isso eu peguei
um GPT que é da do diagrama Ele criou
com base naquelas especificações todo o
diagrama para mim isso levou 4 minutos
então 4 horas que minha funcionária
ficou lá fazendo negócio eu fiz em 4
minutos por que eu tô falando isso
porque já nasceu donos de empresas que
são avaliadas em centenas de milh De
Milhões de Dólares que só tem um cara
[__] só tem um coo e eles falam que
esse ano ainda vai surgir a primeira
empresa de 1 bilhão de dólar que só tem
um funcionário que é o se como é que
isso acontece porque tem um cara fazendo
um monte de coisa com aá fazendo coisa
para ele que é o que eu tenho hoje eu
tenho um monte de a Eu tenho um aia que
chama texto alanan [__] porque eu
percebi assim minha equipe já texto
aliano porque a galera tipo que
respondia ali os meus comentários e tal
às vezes não ficava parecido com que a
forma com que eu falo então eu treinei o
maa com base nos meus textos para ela se
comunicar igual eu então quando eles vão
responder um comentário e-mail eles
colam o o texto lá essa I pega e
modifica o texto para ficar igual a
jeito que eu falo Hum então daí eu criei
vários eu tenho vários esse daí seria um
GPT que tu criou específico para isso
mas por tipo por que que tem que ser um
GPT específico por que não pode ser o
chat de GPT normal pode ser chpt normal
só o que acontece as limitações né tu
vai ter que jogar isso como prompt né No
momento que tu joga isso como prompt tu
já consumiu tokens quando tu cria um GPT
tu tem 8000 caracteres que tu bota lá
num num num arquivo que ele não conta
como
então cada sabe aquela coisa que ele
esquece o que tinha falado ele nunca
mais vai o GPT nunca esquece porque
aquilo ali tá dentro das instruções de
funcionar funcionamento dele é por isso
que tu cria um chat GPT próprio para
tiend fora isso tu pode botar até 20
arquivos com 5 megas cada um cheio de
texto informações que ele vai ler para
poder te dar uma resposta melhor com
base naquilo que tu quer ou seja tu pode
subir lá várias cópias tuas que deram
sucesso e fazer com que ele Leia sempre
aquilo para comparar com o que tu botou
para poder otimizar tem um cara por
exemplo no Twitter que ele já tinha uma
conta com mais de 100000 seguidores ele
pegou e subiu quem que é el lembra não
lembro agora quem que é mas é um dos
caras que eu sigo ali ele jogou 4 anos
de twits dele pro chat nesse GPT
específico ele pediu pro chat GPT ler
tudo Identificar qual que era os modelos
de que ele mais bombava e ele pediu para
que todo twit que ele ia fazer ele
jogava lá e ele escrevia naquele modelo
em dois meses ele tá com 200.000
seguidores uhum aumentou duas vezes o
que ele tinha feito por é isso é muito
poderoso cara hein Eu eu tenho todas as
essas ideias assim só que eu não consigo
de fato aplicar sabe criar um negócio de
F é muito difícil eu percebo eu tem
gente que entende G mas não consegue
aplicar por quê primeiro porque tem
novidade o tempo todo tem muita novidade
é o tempo toda semana e é como se uma
semana no mundo de a é como se fosse um
dois meses no mundo de marketing o
marketing já é acelerado Uhum Então é
muito rápido tudo acontece então é
primeiro é difícil de de acompanhar tudo
segundo que existe muito ruído existe
muita gente que fala que sabe mas não
sabe [__] nenhuma só tá dando dica de
prompt Zinho dica de ferramentinha e daí
tu tu vai pegar a dica desse cara tu
fica preso porque tipo assim o máximo
que ele vai te dar é um promp que ele
mesmo copiou da Gringa e é um copiar e
colar de todo mundo então tu precisa
entender dos fundamentos só que daí Cadê
os fundamentos os fundamentos
normalmente estão num cara que é
cientista que não consegue nem falar
aquilo direito então foi onde eu eu
percebi um GAP eu gosto de eu gosto de
Mar Azul oportunidade de Mar Azul que é
o quê onde eu posso ir chegar lá e
vender muito e eu sou ser único e eu
percebi cara existe um GAP que é tá
faltando um cara que entenda de Business
negócio mas que entenda de tecnologia
também e entenda de pessoas como eu
entendo como na n Life lá eu tive a
gente teve mais de 60 funcionários em
determinado momento Ou seja eu fiz mais
de C contratações era mais de 70 Cara eu
acho que era mais de 70 eu eu acho que
era 70 tá o André fala que eu tô
viajando mas eu acho que era 70 se eu
não me engano que era muita gente era
muita gente era uma galera [__] lá é
então assim eu tô preenchendo esse esse
vazio aqui que é entre o algo que é
muito técnico e algo que é funcional e
daí eu consigo trazer aquilo que é
tecnológico né que é a parte científica
do negócio de uma forma que é funcional
porque assim se tu pegar esses caras que
estão falando hoje aqui a maioria deles
são gente que só pega coisinhas prontas
né se tu pega alguém que realmente foi
lá e estudou que nem tu fez o que que tu
fez tu foi lá e estudou na Essência cop
Tu estudou com os caras que fizeram E é
isso que eu aconselho as pessoas fazerem
não precisa nem me seguir por exemplo eu
sou um cara que busca mas vai na na na
fonte sabe tenta buscar da fonte o que
que tu acha que seria a fonte assim tipo
tu falou que tem os papers lá tal eu
queria fazer duas perguntas PR gente
primeiro o que que tu acha que é a fonte
uhum bom [__] tem tanta coisa mas que
tu vai falando e tu vai abrindo os Loops
entendeu na minha cabeça sim porque a
minha cabeça Ela Só Ela só comporta a
minha memória aqui também é É três
tokens só três Loops no máximo entendeu
Aí eu queria fazer a pergunta como
aplicar o GPT na empresa tá para eu
pegar umas dicas segunda pergunta seria
o negócio dos fundamentos Tipo o que que
tu considera os fundamentos assim que
que uma pessoa enfim teria que que
entender para para saber a fundo da
parada e a terceira cancei Esqueci qual
a terceira que que a gente tá falando
mesmo agora agora a gente tá falando dos
gpts Ah é como estudar a fundo no
negócio Tipo quem quem que o cara vai
estudar assim Sei lá o cara vai estudar
o sei lá o o Alan touring não sei
entendeu que tipo como funciona essa
parada assil olha como é que funciona o
meu o pessoal pede né e engraçado porque
tipo eu tô com uma formação em a que os
alunos os alunos da minha comunidade
pediu para eu criar porque eu nem
pensava em criar isso agora pega essa
vai virar uma pós--graduação [__]
sério mesmo aham vai virar uma
pós-graduação com um certificado [__]
Tod Ah é de Universidade assim [__]
mano e porque não tem ninguém que fala
que ensina o que eu ensino daí a galera
ficou louca e tipo querem me levar para
vho do servício também para fazer uma
imersão lá no Vale do silisto falando
sobre a ô que massa mano então tipo tal
o negócio tá explodindo assim sabe mas
ao mesmo tempo eu vou ter que frear por
causa do nascimento do filho mas é por
isso que eu tô bem louco criando um
monte de ag gente criando monte de coisa
para mim ao mesmo tempo e eu tô querendo
agora um em inglês tem uma expressão só
dos nerds que é é swarm of Agents ou
swarm Agents que é uma eu nem sabia de
jeito que era palavras de pensei não é
enxame é alguma coisa en chame de
abelhas é is som mas acho que alguma
coisa assim enxame é enxame de agência
que é o quê tu cria uma agência hoje
olha que loucura que eu vou falar aqui
hoje tu pode criar uma agência de margem
indireto que é 100% automatizada
faturando tranquilamente R 2 milhões de
reais por mês tá vamos falar sobre isso
isso parece é muito interessante esquece
os fundamentos ali cara é [__] muita
coisa tá mas V falar do rapidinho dos
fundamentos tá fala fund que eu busco
camentos onde é que tá essa galera tá
conversando Twitter discord os melhores
grupos de conversa de estão no discord
Ah é Ah e papers agora tipo assim eu
duvido a galera que tá nos escutando ir
para papers entrar nos discords e ficar
fazendo eu sou meio louco então o que
que eu resolvi fazer eu vou entregar de
graça os fundamentos não só na minha vou
fazer uma semana agora no YouTube mas eu
resolvi fazer o seguinte eu vou entregar
vou criar um curso que vale dois o
pessoal tá por aí vende a R 2.000 r$ 500
e vou entregar de graça pras pessoas com
os fundamentos por que que eu acho Por
que eu quero fazer isso porque cara
ninguém sabe o que é EA Então eu quero
que a pessoa Ela entenda EA consiga
aplicar EA o negócio dela ganhe dinheiro
e ela vai dizer assim cara eu quero mais
coisas desse cara del ela vai vir pra
minha comunidade vai vir pra minha
formação vai vir pra minha mentoria mas
por isso que eu vou resolvi vou fazer um
negócio [__] contratei
uma empresa de metodologia que tá amanhã
eu vou ficar o dia todo com eles
contratei três professores já que vão
est ensinando outras coisas de já também
e vou entregar de graça PR as pessoas
isso pensando longo prazo nembra que a
gente táa falando longo prazo porque eu
vou entregar isso de graça pras pessoas
igual o carinha que tu tá botando um
negócio e faz o Alex hormos ele entrega
tudo de graça eu também vou entregar de
graça as coisas então pra galera que
quer entender os fundamentos já é
realmente começa a me seguir começa a me
acompanhar eu falo o nome da galera que
eu acompanho também então vai descobrir
me acompanhando quem que são os caras
que eu acompanho também caso queira
beber já mais para fonte ainda né sim
mas eu acredito tipo assim e é um espaço
que eu tô prendo no Brasil que não
existe hoje existem muitas pessoas boas
e competentes falando sobre a em
específico na seu campo de atuação Como
é o cas o caso do André Cia Bruno
picinini Ah o André Cia tá falando tá o
Andréia tá falando sobre ia ah ele tá
falando é cop EA fala uma coisa assim
que tem o c o nome dele Cia né assim
interessante e o o Bruno também tem
vários outros caras são bons são
competentes nas suas Áreas e falam sobre
isso então tem gente competente mas
fundamentos eu tô preenchendo espaço que
não existe hoje no mercado pelo menos eu
desconheço que alguém que com essa
profundidade que entende sobre isso
consegue consegue falar cara nesse teu
nível aí de não falando ruim mas de tipo
de energist assim de de sei lá de
estudar sobre essas paradas eu acho que
não tem ninguém não mano que é uma coisa
muito específica sabe e não só isso
também como é difícil é complicado é
difícil eu já tentei ler uns papers Eu
gosto muito de física Como tu sabe eu
fiz engenharia né Sim e eu não entendo
[__] nenhuma mano entendo nada eu até
comprei um livro cara que é que é é tipo
o como o chat ept funciona e que ele
está fazendo e daí ele mostra passo a
passo como é que ele funciona que é tipo
que ele meio que completa ali a tua
frase com base em probabilidade sabe é
uma coisa muito Grand e no começo ele
fala se tu tem poucos parâmetros ele
fala um monte de loucura aí ele vai
evoluindo evoluindo evoluindo e no final
dá uma coisa boa assim é bem
interessante quanto mais parâmetros Tu
tem ou seja mais tu vai ter um caminho
caminhos que ele pode perseguir né só
quanto mais parâmetros mais poder
computacional tu precisa por exemplo eu
comprei um computador nos Estados Unidos
um Mac que é o preço aqui no Brasil de
uma apartamento Quanto ah me custou acho
que foi 10 ou 15.000 e Aqui no Brasil é
vendido acho que por 8.000 [__]
umauma coisa assim
e por eu comprei esse computador porque
eu queria rodar não foi 3 3.000 4 4000 e
Aqui no Brasil é uns 6.000$ 30.000 ala
coisa assim e eu queria rodar o quê eu
queria rodar ias dentro dele então eu
consigo rodar várias ias eu rodo no meu
computador sempre S de internet mas daí
para isso eu preciso de mais poder
computacional para ser não ser tão
devagar vai comprar umas plaquinhas de
vídeo daí eu tenho que comprar PL quem
divide igual o o o zuk lá mas então dia
que a gente tava mesmo tá falando cara
eu que eu queria te perguntar que eu
achei muito interessante como que tu
aplica o GPT no teu dia a dia na na tua
empresa aí e tal os gpts aqueles que tu
consegue personalizar botar botar as
coisas a mais ali e da a segunda a gente
iria migrar aí pra parte de marketing
direto que eu fiquei muito curioso
entendeu eh isso é uma coisa que
especialmente as pessoas estão vendo
aqui a gente eles vão gostar porque a
grande maioria das pessoas tem operação
de marketing direto Uhum mas eu queria
saber primeiro o GPT porque pessoal eu
sou eu sou iG egoísta cara eu quero
aplicar isso a no V turb aí eu quero
saber como que eu posso fazer isso aí
entendeu Como que eu posso até esse
negócio aí que tu falou mais simplesinho
aí de sei lá dar os dados ali pro PR iar
para ela cuspir o texto ali na tua voz
acho que isso deve ser mais de boa né
mais de boa tu vai ter que extrair teu
estilo de eu diria assim ele é de boa
mas exige Ah uma compreensão pelo menos
de sintaxe de português de de entender
formas gramaticais de como tu se
comunica para poder simular porque a ela
é toda certinha ela é toda tipo assim
botar vírgula no lugar certo etc então e
a gente não é assim a gente fala tudo
errado então tem que pegar a forma como
tu fala para tentar e tu tem que criar
inclusive o que que eu percebi eh a
gente tem várias formas de falar
dependendo do ambiente por exemplo
verdade se eu tô falando mandando áudio
no no WhatsApp eu percebi que é um jeito
que eu falo por isso que eu treinei uma
mayak que fala igual eu agora no
WhatsApp para mandar áudios para meus
alunos para lembrar eles das aulas que a
gente vai ter só que daí o que que eu
fiz Como é que eu treinei aessa Yak lá
na 11 Labs eu mandei vários áudios por
por por WhatsApp eu não tenho esse
costume né mas eu mandei vários para
poder pegar bem o jeito que eu falo com
ar ligado cachorro latindo sabe parae
ser natural sim e treinei daí uma versão
lá no Eleven Labs com minha voz de
WhatsApp da Eu tenho uma voz da minha de
Podcast que daí com o microfone que eu
tenho profissional etc Eu tenho minha
voz de aluno Professor Porque daí eu
falo umas coisas diferente o jeito que
eu falo Me empolgo começo a afinar voz
etc Ah é É tipo assim no podcast eu sou
bem-vindo de volta ao podcast F lendária
daí chega na assim ai não sei que lá não
sei que lá que massa então tipo assim eu
peguei e criei Tones diferentes na minha
voz né que interessante cara então são
coisas que eu eu fui percebo entendeu ah
tal desculpa aí não fo nada daí então
assim eu percebi isso por isso que eu
treinei as diferentes então que que eu
fiz por exemplo antes de das minhas
aulas começou a rodar isso onte onem ah
os meus alunos eu aviso eles por áudio E
aí João beleza cara hoje eu vou dar uma
aula sobre como como captar a essência
do texto das pessoas manda isso para
cada aluno não não eu não eu nem falo
nada tipo assim aa faz tudo não Sim mas
tu tu conseguiu criar um sistema cria
manda para cada aluno Ah é E não é só só
o e e João mas eu eu pego Como eu faço
uma pesquisa de onboard com as pessoas
eu tenho lá por que que tu tá no meu
curso qual que tu dificuldade comar eu
tenho tudo então eu tenho um prompt que
eu uso o chat pt4 Turbo via API de 128k
né Ola rapidinho o que que é super
rápido aqui só para citar a galera cara
tem o quatro e tem o quatro turbo tem o
quatro Turbo o que qual que é a
diferença assim é quatro Turbo Ele é
mais rápido e mais barato e tem uma
versão dele que tem 128k de tokens eu eu
tenho acesso a isso aí ou tu tem algum
só criar a tua conta lá na api no op e
botar um cartão de crédito deu acesso a
ele antes era liberado conforme tu eu
tive que pedir liberação porque eu fui
um dos primeiros a ter então tu tem que
se cadastrar etc mas hoje não qualquer
um criar conta lá tem acesso na hora só
para eu ver se eu entendi mesmo isso é
diferente ali do chat GPT Plus lá que eu
ten completamente diferente é outra
coisa é api é tu tem acesso lá por
exemplo tu tem 32.000 tokens e não é o
turbo que tá lá esse Turbo ele é mais R
rápido mais inteligente e tem 128.000
tokens Hum mas eu consigo usar eu como
um lego que não sei programar consegue
porque tu pega ele tem aplicações na
internet que tu bota ali só tu api e tu
consegue conversar com a com o Maya com
ele Ah como se fosse um como se fosse
aquelas carteiras da blockchain ali que
tu uma o o ui ali uma Interface para tu
para conversar com essa P cara que
interessante isso gostei disso examente
então assim tu Peg isso aí tu vai
ensinar na tua formação também eu ensino
na minha formação eu ensino como tu
criar tua própria app inclusive na minha
formação Hum e ou ou virtualizar
qualquer uma tipo assim porque às vezes
por exemplo o mixt que é o mra e existem
as pessoas acham que só existe chpt
existem mais de a gente tá chegando no
número de 500 milhões não 500.000
modelos de a [__] a gente tem hoje Se
for pegar o site que tem esses modelos é
o hugan Face nesse site tem hoje seu ah
hugin Face lá tô ligado né que é a
comunidade de de ai lá os caras discutem
as coisas é tem mais tem 4 mais de
480.000 que aquele emoji do do cara
abraçando né Sei sei então lá tem os
modelos pode baixar Então tem um o
mixtro por exemplo ele é melhor que o
GPT turb em algumas coisas então tu pode
usar cada uma para uma coisa específica
também mas vamos lá vamos vamos tentar
simplificar né Uma das coisas que eu
faço por exemplo Esse é a questão do
áudio que eu pego e mando para todos os
meus alunos antes da aula falando
pessoalmente com eles porque eu pego um
prompt que eu tenho ele lê minha tabela
lá do do Google planilhas que tem todas
as informações dos meus alunos ele pega
o pelo número do celular e o número que
tá no WhatsApp ele ent ele pega essa
pessoa pega fala o nome dela h que tá
ali o primeiro nome e pega alguma coisa
dessa aula que eu vou dar que eu escrevo
ali né para ele as aulas que eu vou teri
e tal fala para como essa aula vai
ajudar essa pessoa que tem esses
problemas específicos ou essas essas
esses desejos específicos então e aí
João beleza cara hoje eu vou dar uma
aula sobre estilo de escrita comar como
tu capitar o estilo de escrita de alguém
e como tu é copywriter e tu quer escalar
o teu negócio aí eu tenho certeza que
essa aula vai te ajudar a conseguir
fazer cópias mais personalizadas então
eu te espero na aula hoje
daí a mesmo eu mando pra outra pessoa E
aí Gabriel Beleza cara tu que é gestor
de tráfego imagina tu pegar e criar
vários criativos com a mesma voz do cara
lá que é o teu Expert por exemplo tu que
tem uma agência de tráfego Então cara a
aula de hoje vai ser massa Sim Isso é
muito interessante cara como que como
que é isso na prática assim tipo eu vou
eu vou precisar do chat GPT Turbo 4 ou
qu Turbo sei lá aí eu vou precisar do 11
Labs vai precisar por exemplo de uma
plataforma que faça a integração entre
eles que eu utilizo hoje o make e o n8n
E tu vai precisar que é a mesma coisa
que o zaper tipo é o zaper E tu vai PR
Por que que todo mundo usa essa [__] aí
cara ninguém usa o zaper parece todo
mundo que eu pergunta Z é muito caro e
não tem tanta funcionalidade digamos
fácil como é o make O make é tipo tu
cria tipo aqueles funil no infusion soft
vai puxando os desenhozinho e vai
conectando então acaba sendo mais fácil
para essa aplicação sim eu uso daí isso
é mais difícil digamos de fazer Ahã
agora por exemplo essa é uma aplicação
que eu f tem em a eu tenho outra
aplicação também que é o quê eu tinha eu
mesmo divulgava ten tem um grupo lá na
minha no meu na minha comunidade que é
um grupo de newsa Então eu ia lá tudo
que eu tava lendo eu pegava e divulgava
pra galera olha galera o que que
aconteceu aqui e tal pra galera ficar em
vez de tu ficar olhando um monte de News
um monte de lugar eu sou esse filtro eu
filtro as informações pras pessoas só
que cara isso é trabalhoso então eu
botei o meu gerente da comunidade para
fazer isso só que tinha dia que ele
esquecia Tinha dia que ele tava na
função lá de atender aluno e fazer coisa
que ele não conseguia fazer e daí eu
pensei assim cara pera aí ele tá fazendo
bem Eu também faço bem isso como é que
eu como é que eu filtro as melhores
informações daí eu fui lá e descobri as
os portais de notícia que eu olhava os
os tweets que eu seguia Ah comecei os
YouTubes que eu eu procurava tá então
vou fazer a ia todos os dias às 8 horas
da manhã ela vai olhar as últimas 24
horas analisar tudo e com base nos
filtros que eu tenho para direcionar ela
vai trazer as informações mas eu quero
que ela escreva do meu jeito então eu
peguei Quem tá lá no grupo de News
recebe todas as novidades que
aconteceram de dia no dia anterior com
base ela faz um resumo de uma forma bem
divertida e tal e com o link com imagem
tudo pra pessoa com o meu estilo de
falar Uhum Então essa é outra aplicação
que eu tenho também que também envolve
daí automações make etc já aconteceu de
da qualidade não ficar boa assim ou ou
então como que tu faz para para garantir
a qualidade desse negócio garantir a
qualidade do negócio envolve uma coisa
chamada engenharia de prompt que que é
engenharia de prompt é basicamente como
tu conversar com a com a ia então no
entro que tu entende como ma ia funciona
por exemplo eu tenho uma eu li ol por
isso que é importância também de estudo
né Eu li um paper chamado que que eles
de 2000 de 2023 dezembro de 2023 que era
sobre tree of thought tipo árvore de
pensamentos e que que os cientistas jar
Descobriram que se tuer criar uma linha
de de pensamento de árvore para num
prompt tu consegue ter
74% mais resultados do que um F shot que
é o promt normal que só escreve e dá
Enter o eles para coisas mais avançadas
então eles botaram lá problemas
extremamente avançados e f shot que é
esse prompt que tu dá de uma vez só ele
conseguiu resolver 4% das vezes esses
problemas mais avançados com GPT 4 só
quando tu faz three of thought tipo
assim essa árvore de pensamentos tu
consegue 74% de atividade para problemas
extremamente avançados e uma coisa que
os copywriters bons hoje utilizam o
próprio aquele cara o o americano lá que
tu fez uma entrevista com ele o Stephan
Stephan George por exemplo ele qualquer
técnica que ele utiliza é uma técnica
bem avançada também de prompt que é Cot
que é chan of thought é cadeia de
pensamentos que ele ele aplica nas
cópias dele que já é mais avançada mas
essa consegue ter 44% de assertividade
three of thought tem 74% de
assertividade então tu tu pode dar um
exemplo assim vou dar um exemplo aqui é
a gente tenta simular no TR of thought ã
uma um processo que acontece já
naturalmente dentro da sua cabeça por
exemplo quando tem um problema tu já não
pensa tipo assim diretamente na solução
muitas vezes tu pensa assim nossa esse
problema vai ser complicado porque por
exemplo vou pegar que nem agora aqui
Floripa é muito trânsito né se eu eu
poderia pensar assim Agora são 6 horas
com certeza tem tem um monte de gente
saindo do do trabalho sexta-feira ainda
sexta-feira ainda então vou pegar muito
trânsito e se Nossa você tá [__] então
se eu continuar falando mais tempo aqui
no podcast e fazer um podcast 3 horas
pode ser que eu pegue menos trânsito
Então vou continuar falando aqui então
entendeu Tipo assim eu fui
contextualizando para chegar e quando tu
faz isso tu tem resultados muito
melhores comhar como é que tu faz isso
tu pode fazer só várias vezes mandando
Prom para ela que vai fazer com que tu
gaste mais token e não é tão
performático ou fazer uma cadeia de
pensamento o que que é essa cadeia de
pensamentos tu pega e fala é muito
simples na prática Pode parecer Nossa
ele deu um paper cara vou te falar agora
como fazer vou criar um prompt agora
sobre cadeia de pensamentos por exemplo
Digamos que eu quero descobrir qual que
é o melhor tipo de prompt para escrever
uma cop que vai fazer com que eu escale
muito vsl e daí eu vou falar para PR
yass eu quero que você pesquise agora
ah pelo menos cinco estratégias de
prompts de engenharia de prompts com
como é bom sempre dar exemplos como o
torch como C como f short e tal eu quero
que tu pesquise isso antes que prisar eu
quero que você identifique Quais são as
vantagens desvantagens de cada um e faça
uma lista disso depois de fazer a lista
eu quero que tu incorpore agora um
Expert de Copy esse ex de de cop ele vai
ler cada ele vai fazer teste ele vai
analisar cada um desses tipos de prompts
e vai dizer por que ele acha que esse
Prom seria melhor para essa função e vai
descrever por que no final ele vai
descrever Por que cada um é melhor
depois eu quero também que tu simule um
analista de cop onde ele vai discutir
com esse cara com esse Expert de copio e
vai refutar as coisas que ele falou e
depois eu quero que tu faça um papel de
Juiz onde esse juiz vai dizer com base
no que foi feito falado pelo cop e Com
base no que foi falado pelo analista
Qual que é a decisão final Qual que é o
melhor prompt para escrever vers caramba
que isso eu fiz a minha cabeça agora
aqui mas claro tipo assim Nem todo mundo
tem a capacidade cognitiva para fazer
isso uhum então tipo assim a minha
cabeça ela é ela funciona assim já
naturalmente S então eu consigo fazer
isso na minha cabeça tanto que quando eu
programava às vezes escrevi o código
inteiro na minha cabeça de alguma coisa
e depois eu escrevia o código lá e
funcionava então talvez não seja Ah mas
eu não tenho essa capacidade cognitiva
que tu tem para fazer isso mas tu ten um
chpt para fazer isso para ti tu pode
pedir para ele com base na estrutura de
tot resolver um problema para ti ele vai
escrever o prompt que vai fazer com que
ele resolva o problema próprio dele e
isso que eu fico pensando como é que a
galera não pensou n antes Nossa Sabe
porque tipo assim eu eu uso o tempo todo
isso eu faço ele escrever o código para
ele mesmo me dá a melhor resposta porque
ele se conhece ele sabe como ele
funciona então eu peço para ele escrever
o código para ele mesmo então por
exemplo aqui o que eu fiz né É como eu
já já uso eu uso tanto e eu tenho uma
frase que eu falo nas minhas imersões
que é o seguinte se tu não tá usando oá
A cada 15 minutos cara tu tá muito
atrasado muito atrasado porque é como a
a gente tem que pensar o seguinte que
que é essas l LM esses gpts essas ias
que a gente tem por aqui são
calculadoras de pensamento então elas
têm a capacidade de previsão de da
próxima palavra Então se tu tem uma
conta matemática difícil ao invés de
pegar aqui um papel que que tu faz hoje
tu abre o celular pega o calculador e
faz ali agora por que que quando tu tem
que pensar que é o tempo todo tu não tá
usando umaa para te ajudar nisso se ela
consegue fazer isso extremamente bem
então toda vez que tu tiver que pensar
tu tem que tá usando uma porque ela é o
teu óculos é a tua tua expansão ela ela
é o teu potencializador ela te potenci
ia então toda vez que eu tenho que tomar
uma decisão toda vez que eu tenho eu por
exemplo eu ten eu criei um GPT que é
mente lendária que basicamente é o quê
eu faço com que mente lendária eu chamei
de mente lendária depois posso até
compartilhar pra galera sees quiserem
usar que que é esse mente lendária eu
criei um GPT que me ajuda a ter Clear
Thinking que é ter um pensamento Claro e
objetivo sobre as coisas da vida então
quando eu largo uma uma dúvida minha lá
ele me ajuda a tomar melhores decisões
então é tipo entre aspas um conselheiro
porque não é um conselheiro Porque
existe os GPT conselheiros também que eu
criei por exemplo eu criei um GPT do cap
gupta capil gupta para quem não conhece
conhece mas ele é o o advisor Né o o o o
Coach do naval R vacante Então eu peguei
joguei todos os livros dele lá no GPT
joguei todos os tweets dele joguei todos
os artigos dele do do poste do do do
blog dele e para qual que faz isso eu
criei uma ia no meu celular que eu
digito qualquer site ali ela vai entrar
em todos os teu todos os teus vídeos do
YouTube vai entrar em todos os teus
sites vai baixar tudo para mim vai botar
no google drive e vai gerar um arquiv
Minho para mim poder subir nesses gpts
subo nos GPT desses arquivos faço
algumas rodadas ali para para extrair o
estilo de linguagem da pessoa e extrair
um pouquinho dos diagramas de decisão
tomar decisão dessa pessoa e daí eu
posso ter um conselheiro que eu crio
esse s é um clone a Eu crio o clone a de
uma pessoa que eu posso tirar dúvidas
com ela sobre algo que ela sabe eu criei
também um um clonado Dan coy que é um
cara que da da internet fala sobre One
Business como eu comprei a mentoria dele
curso dele One Business é ele fala sobre
One bus One personal business seja tipo
assim Como tu constrói um negócio de uma
pessoa só Uhum E daí eu peguei todos os
as os os todos os materiais que eu tinha
da mentoria dele lá do da comunidade
dele joguei no GPT meu pessoal porque
daí eu não preciso ficar olhando
materiais eu só pergunto alguma coisa
por exemplo assim como você tu faz para
escalar com ele acha que ele é oena
então como tu faz para escalar os seus
vídeos no YouTube daí ele pega e fala ah
eu uso essas técnicas aqui e tal Porque
ele encontra no Com base no banco de
dados que ele tem então eu tenho esses
gpts que são os experts então quando tu
tem quando tu entende já o suficiente
para conseguir criar coisas para ti não
faz sentido não tá usando ela o tempo
todo sabe tipo é uma é uma expansão não
tô AF fim de pensar tudo bem então não
USI el mas se tu tiver pensando não faz
sentido Não tá usando ma uhum e Ah mas é
caro e tal não cara existe por exemplo
não sei se tu tem no celular aí mas tem
o pi pi. a que é uma empresa do p não
tenho eu tenho o po o p tá ligado o pa
aham que é que é daquele cara do do Cora
lá sim e tem o chat GPT só mas o p nem
uso não é o p é uma tecnologia a mais
avançada de comunicação que existe hoje
de de falar como como fosse um humano
não é é pi pi e ele é de graça pi. ai é
pi. ai pi pai ele é de graça eles
investiram assim Acho que foi já mais de
100 milhões de dólares na ferramenta e
tu tem de graça no negócio é absurdo que
a gente tá tendo hoje em dia sabe e tu
pode conversar assim ela foi desativada
ela tinha a versão português também
agora tu vai ter que tu pode escrever em
português mas falar só em inglês para
ficar bem bom uhum e cara ela consegue
em tempo real tip assim se tu quiser
assim falar Nossa será que eu sai eu
saio agora do podcast que não vou pegar
trânsito ela vai acessa à internet
Analisa para ver se tem como é que tá o
o o tráfego e tal para te Eu tava nos
Estados Unidos eu perguntei qual que é a
melhor predaria para um brasileiro ir
aqui em Orlando ela pegou e analisou as
respostas das pessoas nos comentários e
me disse olha com base no que a gente já
tá conversando porque ela tem uma uma
técnica de memória um pouquinho mais
longa Então ela Pelas conversas que eu
tava tendo com ela a semana passada ela
me indicou a melhor pizzaria para eu ir
tava falando de pizza ela lembrou ela
gosta de calabresa Ah sim me indicou
então tipo assim é e é de graça tu pode
conversar no WhatsApp tu pode conversar
com ela no no no sim no aplicativo Então
hoje existem recursos precisa nem pagar
para isso mas é aquela coisa tu paga aí
uma pessoa que paga Ó ali por mês para
ter acesso a GPT Plus não vale a pena
pagar ó por mês para ter acesso por
exemplo a el musk para te ficar
perguntando coisa para ele não vale a
pena ter acesso a uma ferramenta que
consegue potencializar teu time inteiro
é por isso que eu paguei r$ 1200 00 para
ter um ano de quatro cadeiras para meu
time porque eu sei o quanto aumenta a
produtividade deles para tudo escrita de
C eles usam para que assim exat então o
que que gente a gente usa todas as TBS
que eu crio eu tô criando com D 3 e não
mais com mid Journey então o que que eu
fiz eu criei lá eu tenho por exemplo
thumbs lendárias que são as thumbs que
eu tenho no meus podcasts que eu tenho
no meus blogs que eu tenho na minha News
Então o que eu faço eu jogo para PR ia o
texto a Lead por exemplo o começo do
texto né título e o começo do texto e
ela vai identificar qual o elemento vai
ser melhor para criar uma imagem que
represente aquele texto que gere uma
instigação da pessoa a querer ler aquilo
e ela cria mais no estilo que eu quero
que é isso daí seria apenas o GPT mesmo
é que nem a mesma coisa que a gente táa
falando antes ali de tu ir lá fazer o
GPT subir ali os arquivos ali isso
exatamente eu inclusive eu subi arquivos
porque ele consegue ler imagens então eu
subi imagens similares que eu gostaria
que ele replicasse Uhum E eu botei
exemplos de prompts que eu já tinha
feito antes que eu gosto Então Criei um
GPT para isso eu tenho GPT que como eu
falei emita estilo de voz eu tenho GPT
que são digamos os especialistas que eu
posso perguntar coisas para eles Eu
tenho um GPT que cria diagramas de
qualquer diagrama de qualquer coisa eu
tenho um GPT que não é meu que é é o
greenore que é do amigo meu americano
que é o nick que ele tem hoje é o GPT
mais usado de para desenvolvimento de
códigos do mundo e o grimor por exemplo
qualquer código que eu quero desenvolver
em Python ele escreve todo o código para
mim ele escreve em português o código
para eu ler e alterar se eu quiser e se
eu dou w enter ele cria o código inteiro
para mim se eu der S ele salva um
arquivo. Python e eu baixo meu
computador na hora então com poucos
atalhos ali eu crio um scripts que eu
tudo tudo isso aqui que eu criei de
integrações eu tô usando Python só que
eu não sei programar Python Nossa e eu
tenho ass eu tenho eu já criei acho que
umas 30 automações diferentes com python
eu não sou programador Python então
assim por que que eu uso a o GPT 4 para
criar os códigos para mim dá um bug eu
copio lá no no terminal o erro que deu
jogo pro grimor por exemplo ou pro GPT 4
ele vai me dizer o que que eu tenho que
fazer qual biblioteca que eu não baixei
qual que linha que tá algum erro eu peço
para ele olha assim ó eu quero criar
isso de forma performática então quero
que o código seja limpo já deixa tudo
para mim corrigido para possíveis erros
que pode gerar e já cria com variáveis
para que eu possa expandir isso como se
fosse uma classe por exemplo para ser
usado por Outras aplicações minhas ele
já cria tudo para mim já me explica o
que eu tenho que instalar que passe que
eu tenho que botar ele faz tudo para mim
então existem vários lá para isso na
minha empresa eu uso esses de escritas
por exemplo a News é todo escrita assim
ah pesquisas eu tenho vários de
Pesquisas eu tenho três ou quatro de
Pesquisas Eu tenho um específico que eu
uso que não foi o que eu criei que é o
conscious que ele faz análise dentro de
de papers então ele entra nos papers faz
análise do que eu quero saber e me traz
o que que eu queria saber com o link pro
paper caso eu queira ler eu tenho um que
eu queri para fazer leitura de paper
porque às vezes o paper é muito complexo
Então eu subo o paper lá ele consegue
fazer análise para mim do paper Paul
deixa eu te interromper rapidinho aqui
cara eh Pelo que eu entendi o GPT ess
esses gpts que tu falou que tu tá
criando eles te ajudam a melhorar um
processo padrão da tua empresa Uhum
Então por exemplo Ah esse aqui queria
tamb Certo Maravilha ISO aí como que tu
define o escopo da tarefa desses caras
no sentido
de eh tipo ah esse GPT ele vai fazer
tamb esse aqui vai fazer tipo headline
esse aqui vai fazer sei lá vamos dizer
que é um anúncio Facebook esse faz tb
esse faz headline esse aqui escreve a
descrição da da cópia do Facebook por
que que tem três Cada um faz uma coisa
por que que não poderia talvez ser um só
que daí faz o anúncio inteiro sabe ou ou
Como que tu defini isso tipo ah eu o
como que define o qu granular vai ser a
tarefa do GPT acho que essa é a pergunta
legal uma pergunta muito boa por que o
erro das pessoas hoje é querer que ele
faça tudo por a gente tá a gente não tá
isso é Adi a gente não tá em Adi ainda a
galera tipo assim nem sabe que é Adi Mas
a gente não tá emedi ainda que é uma
inteligência generativa e artificial
então assim quando tu vai a gente tá no
a a tip assim que é a narrow que Ou seja
a a gente tem uma inteligência
artificial O que que a gente tá vivendo
em 2 14 agora a expansão de4 2024 14 não
nossa 14 2024 a gente vive na era das
eas Sabe por que que eu falei 2014
Porque para mim 2024 é 2014 do Market
digital PR aí ó ou seja Aham eu fi
pensando cara eu tô em 2014 eu tô em
2014 tem que aproveitar 2014 era 15
centavos comprar um liad é entendeu Tipo
assim essa coisa assim eu penso Cara eu
tô em 2014 de eu tenho que detonar esse
negócio porque agora ou nunca é a
oportunidade é a oportunidade tipo assim
eu vi isso de vezes quando eu falo 2014
mesmo porque para mim eu tô 2014 mar
digital Mas vamos lá eu tava falando
mesmo antes do gpts o quão eh falou que
a gente não tá em ai a gente tá em nrow
a gente tá a gente tá nesse transição PR
Adi hoje a o que mais está expandindo em
2024 são as eas multimodais então por
exemplo chat PT o que que é isso aí o
chat GPT ele não é só uma GPT ele não é
só um generative Transformer lá PR
pretrained Transformer ele é um
multimodal por qu com GPT eu consigo
falar por exemplo eu vim para cá no
carro não sei se tu já fez isso alguma
vez eu vim com com ele já já então tipo
assim ele consegue escutar áudios o GPT
tu pode tirar uma foto e mandar para ele
e ele vai explicar o que que tá
acontecendo aqui isso é o Vision então
ele consegue criar imagens então assim
ele é multimodal no sentido que ele
consegue ter várias funções específicas
diferentes e é isso que vai fazer com
que ele atinge Adi porque só com base em
texto ele não vai atingir Adi ele
precisa ter vários estímulos externos
como nós humanos temos então a gente
vive numa época hoje onde a gente está
transitando pra Inteligência Artificial
generativa mas a gente ainda ainda está
tá na Inteligência Artificial específica
que é narrow então por isso que eu eu eu
tentei fazer várias ias eh generativas
né que faziam tudo Inclusive eu tava
criando o Alan ya que fazia tudo ah é é
é generativo ou
generalista generalista tá acho que é
generalista eu não lembro qual que é que
eu não me lembro da esse negócio aí cara
bom depois quero falar sobre isso também
mas enfim continui é melhor o agi é o
que faz tudo e o narrow é o que faz só
uma parada uma parada Então hoje é
melhor com as tecnologias que a gente
tem tu criar e as bem específicas para
cada função porque tu consegue dar
instruções específicas para aqu exemplos
e tudo mais para ela fazer uma coisa
muito bem feita uhum inclusive quando eu
comecei a criar esse en chame de Agentes
para eles poder criar aquela agência lá
que depois a gente vai falar que que são
os gpts que não são gpts são agentes são
outra coisa é programação tá não é bem
programação tem um brasileiro que se
chama João Moura eh ess eu tô em contato
com ele Ele criou o Crew Ai que é a
melhor plataforma hoje de criação de
Agentes no mundo Hum tá super famosa Tá
super em alta assim e ele é um cara
Fantástico assim que criou um negócio
que é maluco mas assim tu só digita tipo
assim tu você entend nada de código e tu
consegue fazer um agente funcionar nada
Ah mas é IMP não mas não precisa
entender de código vamos matar esse cara
[__] é muita coisa vamos matar esse
negócio do do GPT como que a gente faz
aí depois exp o Car fala da gente vamos
focar aqui nos gpts E então os por que
que eu tinha falado até linki né com os
agentes porque assim o que eu percebi
também com os agentes é quanto mais esp
aquele ag gente for melhor ele performa
Uhum Então eu prefiro que esse agente eu
tenha vários agentes e eles trabalhem
para outra agente que trabalha para
outro agente sabe o organograma Sim tu
cria um organograma de Agentes que
trabalh um pro outro a diferença é que
quando a gente tem gpts tu exige um
humano para jogar o input e gerar um
resultado ou seja o humano tem que ir lá
copiar um texto colocar aqui ou pedir
para que ele faça uma coisa o agente tu
dá um comando uma vez e ele vai dar um
jeito ali de fazer aquilo chegar naquela
conclusão só o que acontece tu tá usando
custos de api ali né então pode ser que
tipo assim te Curse 200 tem um cara que
que eu conheço que ele gastou ó PR para
ter uma os agentes chegarem uma
conclusão para ele numa coisa sim para
ter um output lá realmente teve alguma
deficiência que foi voltou n exatamente
ficou indo voltando porque F um l ali
Deu Merda ali is aqui é interessante e
dpts não tu tá tu tá seguro que tu pagou
ó tu tem aquelas 40 mensagens a cada 3
horas dentro do Plus por que que eu
paguei o teams porque além de eu ter um
espaço um workshop um um workspace Onde
eu consigo compartilhar meus gpts entro
no meu time para eles poderem editar eu
tenho tem mensagens a cada 3 horas e eu
tava toda hora exaurindo chegando no
limite porque quando tem gpts começa a
usar o tempo todo porque é muito bom das
atividades da empresas tu vai jogando
ali por exemplo eu criei um GPT pro meu
financeiro que eu jogo qualquer planilha
ali minha por exemplo do de banco ele
consegue reconhecer Quais são os os
gastos que são de de plataformas Quais
são os gastos que são de de assinaturas
ele reconhece tudo que são gastos
pessoais porque a gente eu já
parametrize o que que ele tem que
analisar isso demorava duas TR horas
para meuu financeiro fazer aí a faz em
30 segundos então tudo que tudo na minha
empresa que eu percebo que é um processo
repetido eu pego transformo num GPT uhum
e isso faz com que o que hoje na empresa
eu tenho uma regra que é cada setor não
pode ter mais do que duas pessoas
operando aquele setor ah quantos
atendentes tu tem tem um o porque o
resto tem que ser tudo e a Eh quantos
vendedores tu tem tem um tudo tem que
ter um o resto são Eos do lado dele ou
então eu potencializo aquela pessoa mas
eu já tô tem percebido que tem vários
setores da empresa que não precisa nem
de uma pessoa mais e vai poder ser 100%
e a por por exemplo assim tipo qual o
setor Que setor que eu vou deixar 100%
100 pessoas atendimento vai ser ia
porque tá respondendo muito melhor que
pessoas em logo mais social selling vai
ser só um agente fazendo todo social
selling muito melhor que qualquer humano
que eu já já vi social selling seria a
pessoa ficar conversando no Instagram al
isso processo de venda através do
Instagram tu o que acontece a pessoa por
exemplo começou a te seguir que que a aá
tá fazendo que a gente tá eu tô criando
lá ela ela a ela entra no perfil da
pessoa através do GPT 4 Vision ele olha
três quadros da da pessoa olha a Bill L
Bill e começa a ver as fotos e daí tem
uma coisa que um amigo meu ele fala
assim ele vai analisar se a pessoa tem
cara de pixel ou não ou seja se a pessoa
tem condições de pagar ou não cara de
pix cara de pix então assim ess o GPT
esse GPT ele Analisa se a pessoa tem
cara de pix que é o quê Ah eu desenho
Qual que é o meu avatar que eu quero
vender e se pelas fotos pela Bio por
tudo comparado aos gpts que as pessoas
que já compraram meus produtos eu sei
que aquela pessoa tem uma
compatibilidade ou não então se ela tem
cara de pix ele vai analisar e vai
mandar uma mensagem privada PR pessoa
dizend olha que legal que tu é gestor de
tráfego Senor tá usando o ipro aí eu vi
que tu tava no evento da monetize semana
passada como é que foi foi massa
automaticamente manda e depois fica
conversando com a pessoa levando
processo através de spinell através de
várias técnicas pra venda pro meu closer
que depois vai virar um I também
Ah cara se o closer virar ya [__] eu
vou pagar muito pau cara vai vai virar
porque o o social selling eu consigo
entender o atendimento também consig mas
é bem humanizado o social selling tem
que ser bem sim bem específico e o
closer também vai vai virar i cara isso
é muito interessante mas ol é só para
ver você entender o
gpts eles são eles que vão se comunicar
ali na no organograma que tu criou ou
são os agentes não são os agentes os
agentes é como se fosse um GPT infinito
pensa é os GP pensa que os gpts eles são
ferramentas é como se tu desse
ferramentas pro teu tipo assim comprei o
mouse para ti pra gente trabalhar é Tu
deu uma ferramenta pra pessoa da tua
equipe para ela poder performar mais
então invés de ela por exemplo antes ela
tinha que fazer por exemplo financeiro
tinha que fazer toda uma análise lá
Abrir olhar item por item Agora ele só
pega um PDF joga pro GPT ele faz toda a
análise para ele e baixa a planilha
ainda então ele não precisa mais ficar
fazendo análise financeira nesse nível
que abre espaço para que outr essa mesma
pessoa possa ter mais funções na tua
empresa porque aquilo que tomava tempo
dela não toma mais tempo Uhum E esse
esse negócio eu ia fazer diagrama para
toda empresa e Pops para toda a minha
empresa e daí eu ia botar essa essa
minha funcionária para fazer isso só
como eu consegui fazer com que a ia faça
isso eu vou alocar ela para outra coisa
a ia vai fazer todos todos os diagramas
de todos os própios da minha empresa
então tu ganha mais espaço de tempo
então esses gpts eles funcionam como se
fosse ferramentas agentes são como se
fossem funcionários então GPT são
agentes são ferramentas que
potencializam seus funcionários humanos
GPT substitui seus funcionários humanos
o o agente substituir o agente isso tu
tu não consegue bom fazer falar uma
loucura tu tu
sei lá dá um GPT para um agente isso não
rola porque o o é rola rola tipo assim
porque os gpts eles tem uma outra versão
deles que só quem tem acesso via api lá
via servidor tem mas qualquer pessoa
pode ter que são os assistentes os
assistentes são são gpts com esteroides
mas que aí tu tem que entender um pouco
de código para utilizar eles porque daí
eles são vi api que tu usa então tu vai
ter que é a mesma configuração botar
nome lá descrição e tal subir arquivos
só que eles são acessados vi ap então tu
pode criar todos esses gpts por que que
eu tô criando tanto GPT eu tô criando
vários eu devo estar com uns 12 gpts já
da minha empresa porque todos eles eu
vou transformar depois em em assistentes
que corresponde a Api para quem quem vai
utilizar eles vai em vez de ser um um um
funcionário humano vai ser um
funcionário ag gente porque daí ele vai
usar os rpts
hum cara pelo que eu tô entendendo tá o
uso dos dos gpts e
do dos gpts tá uhum gpts é muito de tu
conseguir escalar tua operação com
poucas pessoas né Uhum mas se tu não tem
o que escalar então será que tem alguma
utilidade tipo muito alta assim por
exemplo sei lá a gente tá no nosso
podcast aqui a gente tá conversando aqui
e tal isso aqui vai gerar um episódio
esse epis esse episódio vai gerar reels
Uhum aí o GPT que o GPT por exemplo eu
poderia treinar ele para selecionar os
views daqui né Colocando vários views lá
que deram certo falar olha é tá aqui tá
a transcrição do episódio e me diz aqui
qual etapa de de quando até quanto que
eu deveria cortar isso aqui para criar
um R que daria certo e também uma
headline isso eu conseguiria fazer né
conseguiria entre aspas como eu aí tá e
as pessoas isso não tá nem da nem na
documentação da op porque assim qualquer
atualização que tem da op qualquer
ferramenta que eu uso eu Lio toda a
documentação e que que eu percebi Quando
eu mandava um arquivo às vezes eu
percebi que ela alucinava que que
alucinar ela começa a viajar na
batatinha porque ela falta informações
para e daí só que o que acontece quando
tu manda um arquivo pra Open ela usa o
cod Inter trapt dela que é uma função
que vai analisar o teu arquivo que tu
foi enviado se tu clicar naquele quando
el falar assim analisando tu pode clicar
naquela setinha e tu vai ver o que tá
acontecendo via código em tempo real e
daí eu vi que ela limita a 500
caracteres quando tu sobe um arquivo
para ela no GPT Então isso que a gente
tá falando aqui a gente tá falando
tempão Com certeza já passou de 500
caracteres tipo assim então não vai
funcionar dentro do GPT daí tu teria que
usar um assistente porque o assistente
viap tem 128k daí ele vai conseguir ler
ou tu usa o cloud Ai que é de graça por
200k daí lá sim então quando tu conhece
como funciona as ferramentas o que que é
toen como funciona qual que a limitação
dessa aqui tu saberia por exemplo assim
eu nem vou criar um GPT para isso para
fazer cortes porque ele não vai ter
capacidade de poder fazer a leitura de
Du horas de conteúdo então qu tu nem
perde tempo tu vai direto pro Cloud
então eu vou criar no Cloud isso ah não
mas tem como criar um GPT como se fosse
o cloud tem daí lembra que tu falou do
poi o poi tu tem acesso por exemplo tu
tem como ele foi que criou esses gpts o
poi criou essa modalidade ele chamou de
chatbots personalizáveis e lá tu pode
escolher o cloud ai de 200k para criar
um GPT com ele então tu poderia utilizar
o clou II o poi com clou II para fazer
isso por exemplo Uhum Então como eu
conheço profundamente as melhores
ferramentas do mercado eu quando tu me
fala um problema teu eu consigo na hora
já pensar uma solução com ia ent aí
seria uma ferramenta específica porque
essa ferramenta vai ter essas
capacidades aqui de essa memória aqui e
tal que vai conseguir executar essa
função específica aí no caso dos reals
não daria certo GPT porque ele tem esse
limite de caracteris aí mas se fosse no
Cloud aí ou eventualmente uma outra
coisa aí rolaria rolaria Entendi então
então tu para tu conseguir fazer essas
automações tu precisa necessariamente
conhecer a ferramenta que tu tá usando
coner de prefer profundamente Ou seja a
nível de tu entender a o a documentação
delas Ah não quero saber aqui tá a
aplicação de outro GPT não quero saber
não quero ler a documentação então sobe
a documentação de todas essas essas
essas ferramentas num GPT e toda vez que
tu pensar em criar alguma coisa F que eu
tenho agora eu sempre tenho assim essas
ideias de gpts eu tenho que até anotar
para poder criar o GPT Uhum mas eu
qualquer coisa eu olho esse vídeo de
novo e lembro mas é o quê cria um GPT
que com todas as documentações tu vai
subir documentação no arquivo deles Ah
mas ele lê só 500 não ele lê 500 quando
tu envia o arquivo se tu subir no
knowledge base deles que é que é o banco
de dados dele ele vai fazer uma coisa
chamada ã vetorização por chunks então
ele vai pegar aquelas informações vai
quebrar para Monte pedacinho para quando
fazer uma pergunta ele encontrar esses
pedacinhos e conseguir te dar uma
resposta então lá tu pode subir bastante
arquivo de 5 m com um monte de coisa
porque ele vai quebrar esse pedacinhos
para poder ler depois então tu pega a
documentação da Leven Labs da da Open do
Cloud de todos eles Joga lá dentro e daí
tu faz uma pergunta qual ferramenta qual
ou qual ou qual conjunto de ferramentas
é necessário para que eu faça um uma uma
automação em a para T função ele vai ler
as documentações e vai te dar soluções
por exemplo é uma forma de criar um GPT
para isso ah não quero pensar issso
falando porque eu não quero saber isso
Beleza cria um GPT para isso E aí que tá
cara tu é preguiçoso para pensar melhor
coisa é criar um GPT eu crio muit GPT
para pensar para mim sim interessante E
tá beleza entendi e cara e e e os
Agentes tá o o os agentes parece que é é
um é é um GPT só que turbinado porque
ele não tem os limites né tu vai pagando
conforme ele
vai processualizar ali o negócio aí tu
falou que em teoria ele substitui um teu
um funcionário digamos sim tu tá usando
isso aí hoje como é que funciona Tenho
usado para algumas coisas mas é algo que
eu tô me aprofundando de verdade agora
então assim h eu tenho já alguns gpts
por exemplo para criar cop eu não
aconselho tipo ass gpts ou agentes
desculpa agentes uhum ag para criar cop
é muito melhor ter uma gente do que tu
tem um GPT muito melhor infinitamente
melhor qu Qual que é a diferença assim
por exemplo porque olha só que que é o
vamos pegar o presso de cópia e vão
quebrar ele começa por quê pesquisa tá
então tem que fazer pesquisa tu percebe
que tipo assim são vários passos que são
feitos durante uma uma uma cópia
inclusive testar sim então se a gente
pegasse conseguisse quebrar isso em
várias etapas tu vai vai criar um agente
para cada coisa pera que o agente é
assim um funcionário vamos chamar de
funcionário tu vai criar um funcionário
para cada coisa esse funcionário ele tem
um backstory ou ele sabe o que que ele
tem ele qual que que que tu é aquela
coisa tu é um expert em pesquisa para
criação de Cops Ah tu tem uma habilidade
de conseguir ler papers e descobrir Big
extrair Big ideas dela e daí tu vai
dizer para ele isso com backstory tu vai
dizer para ele ó teu papel aqui é
conseguir melor extrair papers a melhor
as melhores bicadas e daí tu vai dar uma
atividade para ele uma tesque
basicamente um agente ele funciona com
a a a o papel né que tu vai dar para ele
as test que são dele e tu pode dizer
para ele com quais recursos ele tem
então tu pode dizer assim para ele cara
para tu tem acesso a internet e tu pode
mandar nesse nesse nesse agente que é o
quê quando ele achar que ele precisa ol
que interessante Nossa ele vai chamar
esse cara aqui para executar uma coisa
então por exemplo assim daí J tu cria o
agente que faz pesquisa dentro de paper
daí tu vai criar uma atividade para ele
que é criar um criar achar uma big Idea
de emagrecimento que use kitzan por
exemplo tem existe né kitzan existe
então assim tu vai ter que achar alguma
bidia que que utilize kitzan uhum daí
ele vai ficar lá paper paper paper até
ele encontrar alguma coisa legal daí tu
po Claro tu vai ter que definir para ele
o que que é uma bigia como como ele vai
lar e daí tu pode ter o que para ele
inclusive tu pode criar aqui o o teu
funcionário analista esse aqui é o
crítico ele vai olhar as bigad dias
desse cara que ele trouxe e ele vai
dizer para esse cara assim não gostei
não tá aprovado tá ruim e daí ele vai
dizer assim e quando tá ruim que
acontece tu manda ele fazer de novo e
daí tu manda de novo para ele ele vai
começar a procurar e daí por exemplo na
terceira vez ele sabe que na terceira
vez que que o analista falar que deu
ruim ele precisa daí começar a chamar os
universitários então ele vai chamar um
outro analista que é espec
em criação de papers e esse cara vai vai
criar papers fakes por exemplo que é um
outro agente que tem inputs que que ele
pode trabalhar de maneira em teoria
ilimitada conforme tá pagando ali é
exatamente Então o que acontece vai
criando essas esses isso aqui eu tô
falando né uma coisa ah achou Digamos
que o o analista diz assim beleza essa
aqui essa bigia tá validada gostei dela
vai próxima etapa próxima etapa vai
partir pro quê PR Badia Ah então agora a
gente tem que conseguir sei lá criar
criar boas headlines com essa essa ideia
aqui ã ou melhor vamos agora pensar em
formulação de produtos que tenam essa
Big idia que a gente possa comportar
essa Big idia esse aqui é digamos é o
pharmacêutico daí ele é especializado em
análise farmacêutica ele pode ter acesso
a um banco de dados inteiro ã sobre
sobre a coisas por exemplo assim esse
cara esse o farmacêutico ele poderia ter
acesso a um a um ponto um ponto csv ou
uma uma via API de uma de uma empresa
que faz para ti os teus produtos de
cosméticos e suplementos e ele vai ver o
que que
tem lá de de de de de de componentes né
que poderia ser utilizados para criação
de algo que correspondesse a essa
pigadia e daí quando ele diz assim ó
beleza encontrei a gente vai criar aqui
um cosmético de tal coisa usei isso ele
vai dizer assim beleza meu trabalho tá
feito Daí pode ter até um outro que vai
validar isso e vai pro próximo o próximo
vai dizer assim beleza é o copywriter de
de headlines e leads e ele vai criar
essa parte de headlines leads Com base
no produto e com base na bidia e assim
vai indo entendeu Até que tu chegou no
final tu vai sair no final assim eu
tenho o que que eu quero de produto
final eu quero que tenha uma vsl eu
quero que tenha 10 criativos eu quero
que tenha cinco ldes diferentes pra
gente fazer teste AB eu quero que tenha
cinco headlines diferentes e eu quero
ter duas bigad dihas diferentes ou seja
o dobro disso aqui o ag se tu configurar
os agentes certos vai chegar vai ficar
rodando ali no pode rodar no teu próprio
computador Uhum vai chegar no final vai
ter tudo isso aqui que doidura daí que
tu pode fazer ainda tu pode ter uma a
gente que sobe esses ads que cria as
imagens tu vai ter outro ag gente que
sobe isso no Facebook Vi ap e vai rodar
e tu pode ter um agente que é um gestor
de tráfego que fica fazendo já tem muita
gente que faz isso dá o bid certo na
hora certa ou seja tipo assim tu em vez
de tu deixar aberto ali tu tu vai vai
analisando em tempo real o mercado Ah
beleza o bid tem menos gente anunciando
essa hora vou testar vou aumentar aqui o
bid beleza tá vendendo mais e tu pode
ter um outro que é o analista de vendas
Que beleza se tu bater aqui o cpax e y z
escala Se começar a vender Opa vamos
criar mais criativa Ah então vou mandar
uma uma mensagem para quem que quem que
ele comanda ele pode mandar uma mensagem
daí pro cara que cria criativo para ele
começar a criar mais criativo eu preciso
mais cinco criativo para subir aqui
porque asas bases está ruim cara a
oferta não tá convertendo mais os meus
dados aqui estão batendo dos dos meus
dos meus criativos bate eu tô com CTR
bom eu tô com CPC bom só que não tá
convertendo parou de converter Ah então
vamos jogar lá pro research lá pro pro
que faz análise de pesquisa para ele
descobrir uma nova bidia da ele começa
por isso que eu falei que tu tem como
criar uma agência inteira e funciona
inteiro end sem precisar de um humano
entendi e cara e e na prática assim tá
vamos dizer que eu quero criar um agente
o que que eu teria que fazer o GPT eu
tenho mais ou menos uma ideia pelo menos
no chat GPT tá eu não sei que é mais
simples criar um GPT Ah é um agente um
agente assim Claro que vai fazer uma
função extremamente básica só para te
dizer assim Criei um agente inclusive tu
tem hoje se tu for baixar o por exemplo
o Crew ou outro que tem criação de
Agentes e tu pode baixar modelos já lá
do kiub com pré pré processos prontos já
PR treino pré treinamentos prontos é n
ser um treinamento seria arquivos que já
tem vários papéis prontos por exemplo
assim lá já vi que tem agente de viagem
ou seja tu diz para onde tu vai viajar
ele vai pesquisar na internet Quais são
os melhores hotéis daquele lugar qual
que é a melhor passagem vai ter vários
agentes ali dentro cada um vai fazer uma
coisa um vai fazer o booking já da tua
passagem Caso tu bota dar os dados lá
para ele poder fazer isso tem um lá que
é de educação tem vários então tu pode
pegar já isso pronto para poder até
olhar e tu vai ver que simples vai ser
assim ah você vai escrever funcionário
ponto dois igual a Agent P crei daí tu
abre aspas E Tu Come escrever Roll que é
o papel dele é tal ah personalidade tal
sabe então é simples tu pega um template
ali só escreve e outra coisa tem um GPT
que é o Crew ai GPT que foi criado pelo
João também e que tu simplesmente vai lá
escreve o que tu quer fazer quero criar
uma agência que faz tal coisa ele vai
criar para ti os agentes o código em
português tu copia e cola e e deu tá
funcionando que loucura mano que doidura
é isso cara [__] isso isso isso é muito
revolucionário é é de explodir a cabeça
né eu consigo dormir direito exp cabeç é
complicado Hoje eu tava conversando com
o cara o cara falou o meu médico né ele
falou cara você tá dormindo só 6 horas
tu tem que dormir mais eu como é que eu
vou dormir com tudo isso nossa queria
ser tu cara tô dormindo 10 horas tô
muito horas tô dormindo 6 horas que eu
tô assim tô caindo e pum uma pedra tô
muito muito ougado assim com isso né eu
fico lendo de noite paper tipo a gente
dormir sabe e e desculpa pode é porque
tipo é por causa disso porque a gente
tem 2014 do mar digital se pudesse
voltar bota João com conhecimento tem
hoje de mar digital em 2014 ó o estor
que tu vai fazer a gente ia ter chego
aqui de de jato Eu sim estacionar aqui
em cima no L ponto que eu i dar aqui pro
PR pro pro Anderson que não é Alexandre
Anderson e cara
e hoje em dia na bom tu tem Aliás a tua
formação Pelo que eu entendi então tu
vai ensinar as
pessoas como que elas podem aplicar
esses
processos em empresas comuns exatamente
is aqui então tipo tu vai pegar um
moleque ali tipo ó só tu vai aprender a
sei lá programar aqui os gpts e os
Agentes para daí tu oferecer uma
consultoria barra assessoria para uma
empresa e daí automatizar os processos
deles correto uhum Maravilha
eh eu sei que tu tem uma comunidade né
Não não é a mesma coisa que a formação
formação é uma coisa diferente é é o que
eu pensei eu pensei essa esa de
transformação Então eu tenho o
fundamentos de a que eu vou
disponibilizar de graça pra galera
através do treinamento daí eu tenho a
comunidade onde lá tu tem digamos tudo
que tu precisa saber de A tá lá então é
isso tudo que tu precisa saber de A tá
lá então aquela do do CCO lá que eu tô
lá é isso as novidades tem grupos no
WhatsApp onde a galera fica trocando
ideia de a sobre é bem engajado lá o
grupo lá todo dia lá tá subindo nunca vi
cara o
grupozema ele é travado tu sabe que eu
sou ruim de WhatsApp né porque eu dei
WhatsApp para vocês aí do do vtube aí em
vez de vocês falar com suporte vai lá no
WhatsApp do João ferro no João cara a
gente tem que botar uma I no teu
WhatsApp é o que eu botei no Seria muito
bom é E carho então eu falo Coia de vez
em quando não ela tá no meu ia na meu
meu número 51 lá meu número que é sei é
meu número que é tipo assim meu número
antigo tá com ia porque lá é onde os
meus alunos falam comigo então lá
responde eles meu número pessoal mas eu
tô quase botando jamaa no meu pessoal
também porque tipo assim algumas coisas
Vai facilitar É eu gostaria de ter isso
aí é mas tipo assim
eh tá beleza daí na comunidade tem tu
tem tudo o que a pess sa comunidade tem
tudo que prisa saber ag e na comunidade
eu vou começar a ensinar a galera a
ganhar dinheiro comhar também para eles
poderem comprar porque tem muita gente
que quer comprar formação mas não não
consegue porque hoje em dia não tem
recurso então eu vou ensinar eles a
criarem chatbots mas chatbot de verdade
não que essa galera fica mentindo por aí
na internet que vende chatbot porque a
galera faz o quê faz uma automação e
fala que é chatbot não é como tu criar
uma uma ia inteligente que falea igual a
pessoa e que vai responder o Instagram
dela o WhatsApp dela isso é um chatbot
agora quem quer aprender agentes quem
quer aprender a criar gpts avançados
quem quer criar coisa avançada para
ganhar muito dinheiro com isso por
exemplo eu já vendi serviços de a por R
88.000 o que que que [__] de oito cara
ah tá por causa do infinito né causa do
infinito nunca vi mano o bicho tudo oito
é se não for oito o bicho não vem tá
ligado tudo pior que tipo tem já tem tem
um negócio que i vender por a minha
imersão pessoal vamos vender por 20 eu
falei não tem que ser oito então vai ser
por 18 mas vai perder 2000 mas tem que
ser 18 tem que ter oito que é queria
também a questão de marca né boa então
assim é a comunidade também a comunidade
é 1488 né Eu tenho oito mas foi vendido
inicialmente a 888 sim é eu lembro e
agora essa essa imersão ela a a formação
é 8.000 Ah tá então a comunidade 1500 tu
tem acesso a tudo que tu precisa saber
de A então se tu paga 1500 ali tu não
precisa mais ter comprar outras outros
cursos porque tudo eu tô botando ali que
tem de a isso é uma coisa que tá
alimentando de maneira recorrente que
que eu não sei se aquele News e a lá
isso isso é um serviço da comunidade é
uma servo da comunidade Ah tá da tu
atualiza a galera ali então ali tá Por
exemplo agora o mayak faz isso de forma
extremamente excepcional Uhum E é é eu
tenho outra que eu só prompts prompts
avançados já tá sendo Por enquanto é meu
time que faz mas daqui a pouco vai ser
Maiar também e eu tô com vários
professores Além de estar eu tô com
corpo de professores né E também tô com
agora metodologia tô com uma uma empresa
focada em criação de metodologias de
ensino dentro porque eu quero que as
pessoas aprendam Então assim tô
investindo em metodologia pra galera
aprender mesmo dentro da comunidade Daí
vem a formação que vai virar essa
pós-graduação que é a galera tipo assim
o R mas tipo assim vale mais do que uma
faculdade que custa R 200.000 porque eu
vou te ensinar a ganhar tranquilamente
ali uns R 30.000 por mês com que e eu já
tô passando o que qual foi o que eu
falei PR os alunos né eu tô cheio de
cliente aqui querendo que eu faça
automação para eles mas eu gosto de
ensinar e eu gosto de estar criando as
coisas que eu tô criando aqui eu não
quero mais saber de cliente enchando
saco al no meu WhatsApp eu passo os
clientes que estão chegando para mim
para vocês então já tem cinco alunos que
estão atendendo clientes que chegam para
mim e eu falo para eles Olha eu não eu
tenho alunos que fazem isso então eu vou
entregando os meus melhores alunos e vou
entregando os clientes que chegam para
mim boa É de fato isso é é uma coisa tem
muito mais alavancagem né porque daí tu
consegue
eh ser essa plataforma aí onde tu as
pessoas fazem negócio atravel de
ex sendo É eu tô sendo esse Hub né tipo
assim porque eu tô inclusive a minha
formação ela vai ser já usada para
como como decisão de para contratação de
especialistas em a porque que eu vejo a
partir tem uma uma frase que foi do acho
que foi do Bill Gates que ele falou que
foi assim cara a empresa que não
contratar a as as em 2024 já as empresas
que não contratarem alguém de a elas vão
ficar muito para trás e eu percebi eu
achei que tu tinha que contratar uma
pessoa só que eu comecei a chamar a
formação de gestoria que é alguém que
entende de a que vai fazer o teu negócio
acontecer mas tu precisa de três pessoas
na tua empresa só que são três pessoas
na tua empresa que vão fazer com que tu
possa demitir ou fazer com que tua tua
equipe performa muito mais tu precisa
ter um cara que entende de automações
comar que esse cara vai entender de me
que 8n servidor Esse cara é o cara que
entende mais de código tu vai ter que
ter um cara que entende muitas de prompt
que esse cara pode ser teu copywriter de
preferência mas que ele seja um
copywriter que entenda muito de prompt e
tu tem que ter um cara que entenda de
dados porque a ia a diferença que eu
notei eu consigo às vezes ter resultado
equivalente ao GPT 4 com 3.5 Hum como
através de engenharia de prompt e
tratamento de dados eu consigo ter
resultado porque assim tu começa vai
perceber tu começa a usar vipi o qu tu
vai começar a gastar tipo assim eu tenho
eu botei uma um chatbot no meu site vou
falar de resultados por exemplo aqui ah
mal configurado
alguém da minha equipe pegou lá fez em
meia hora esse chatbot botou no meu site
quando eu lancei o curso mente lendária
que é um curso de de organização com
criação de segundo cérebro e tal a gente
só deixou lá o chatbot as pessoas
chegavam no site tinham dúvidas clicava
ali falavam com esse chatbot achando
tipo assim digitavam mesmo não é ficar
selecionando menu sabe digitar conversar
com ele e dele saiu ah 12 vendas de 888
e meu custo dessas da conversa que teve
ali que não tava otimizado foi 55 Ou
seja eu eu gastei Via AP 55 mas eu vendi
12 eu fiz 12 vendas de 8888 que vieram
por ele porque a gente estava traendo as
vendas que vinham através do link que
ele mandava PR as pessoas sendo que ele
não era um agente o ideal é tu ter um
agente de venda que o agente de venda
vai aplicar esse pin selling por exemplo
eu crii um agente de venda para uma
faculdade que ele ele com poucas
interações ele sabe qual que é o disco
anagrama da pessoa e com base no perfil
comportamental da pessoa ele vai seguir
conversando com a pessoa isso é um
agente ele consegue fazer isso um
chatbot é só um chatbot el só tipo assim
responde dúvidas específicas e mesmo
assim ele fez 12 vendas de 888 com 55 é
um é um [__] ruas Sem dúvida com e foi
30 minutos para configurar ele uhum
absurdo e e Ola então por exemplo essas
pessoas que contratam esse esse gestor
de Inteligência Artificial aí
[Música]
eh o o o que que seria basicamente os
serviços que que eles mais prestam assim
o talvez sei lá o o feijão com arroz
assim que eles fariam a primeira coisa
que esse cara vai fazer que eu tô
treinando eles para fazerem isso né É
eles vão dar um trabalho de consultoria
no sentido tipo assim vai entrar e ver o
que tudo que tu a empresa faz e daí vê
assim cara tá sendo ineficiente aqui
aqui aqui porque a gente poderia
automatizar já isso então ele vai
começar a automatizar as coisas depois é
pensar tipo assim o que que a gente
poderia criar aqui de Agentes dentro do
negócio para criar agentes automatizar é
automação e gpts que que a gente pode
criar ferramentas que a gente pode
automatizar daí por fim no momento que
tu tem isso daí a gente vai paraa automa
os ag criação de Agentes que é o que que
a gente pode criar de Agentes por
exemplo que vão fazer o trabalho de
venda o trabalho de criação de imagens
trabalho de Copy e tudo que tu imaginar
claro que exige um conhecimento muito
mais avançado de a conhecimento mais
avançado de apis Então não é qualquer
pessoa a gente é difícil e é um trabalho
caro tipo assim eu falo vocês querem
quem faz minha formação pode
especializar em ser consultor em ser
criador de chatbots em ser criador de
automações em ser alguém que
especializado em tratamento de dados e
também agentes agentes é bem mais
difícil então assim eu tô ensinando
minha formação o passo in Inicial
provavelmente eu vou posso fazer a
próxima turma de formação que é uma
ideia que surgiu agora aqui que é são em
agentes eu vou ter uma formação que é só
sobre agentes sim uma coisa que eu
pensei que tipo o cara ele tem que ter
um
conhecimento do negócio do cliente
profundo para ele saber qual que é o
8020 do negócio e o que que vale a pena
ele ser sei lá automatizado ou não sabe
porque senão Talvez ele escal uma coisa
que que é que não deveria ser escalado
de primeiro lugar sabe então o que que
ele tem que fazer o que que o ideal né
eu falo assim quem eu falo pra galera
tipo cop é uma coisa que assim é muito
difícil achar um copywriter muito bom a
gente sabe disso Life a gente tentou
treinar um monte foi muito difícil de
achar quem escrevia as melhores cópias
no fim era
tu e eu acredito que o cara na minha
empresa eu tenho uma copywriter
maravilhosa que é a Ju mas como eu
estudo muito I as melhores ideias de de
de de gancho são minhas porque não é
porque eu sou o melhor copywriter que
ela mas porque eu entendo mais do
negócio do que ela sim então e eu também
tenho conhecimento de c Então não é
porque eu sou melhor cop Mas como eu
entendo mais o negócio eu consigo achar
ganchos que são muito bons então eu
acredito muito que o próprio empresário
ele precisa entender de cop se ele quer
fazer vendas ou alguém que tá
responsável por vendas a mesma coisa eu
acredito que todo empresário ele tem que
entender o mínimo de como é que aa
funciona para saber onde aplicar na
própria É verdade sem dúvida então o
próprio empresário por isso que eu criei
a mês que vem v vou ativar um grupo de
mentoria de a que é só Empresário que
daí pra galera entender porque eu tava
fazendo as imersões né a imersão era TRS
dias comigo eu ficava mostrando tudo vai
fazer a galera seria louca e agora como
é que eu vou aplicar isso eu não tenho
tempo para aplicar isso daí eu [__]
Criei um problema vou resolver com a
formação daí eu treino pessoas para
resolver esse problema dos caras Uhum E
agora agora que eu tô com três turmas a
terceira turma tá iniciando a formação
eu tô começando a ter gente só que os
melhores já contratei para mim por
exempo essa formação aí dos 8k já já tá
na terceira turma ou vai vai ser a
primeira vez que tu vai fazer agora tô
abrindo a terceira turma já Ah é Ah tá
vai começar dia 29 dia de 2 de fevereiro
mas já tem duas turmas de andamento mas
esse negócio que tu tá fazendo aí que tá
rolando vai rolar um meio que um
lançamento assim um evento é eu vou
fazer sete dias de Live ou oito dias não
sei eu acho que vai ser vai acabar sendo
oito dias aham meio-dia e oit vai ser eu
até tava brincando com a Jude fazer
assim falar vai ser o almoço com Alan
sabe porque tipo assim vai ser no almoço
no horo do almoço então vai ser eu vou
ficar isso que eu tava falando aqui
Claro a gente acabou entrando como tu
também consegue entender mais abstração
a gente entrou em assuntos bem mais
profundos mas minha ideia é o quê
introduzir a galera de uma forma bem
leve para isso é por isso que amanhã vou
ficar 4 horas com uma especialista em
metodologia para esse conhecimento que
eu tenho que é muito avançado quebrar de
forma que seja fácil das pessoas
entenderem Então vou ficar Amanhã 4
horas com uma uma uma pedagoga não é
pedagoga galera um especialista em
metodologia para quebrar esse
aprendizado de uma forma que seja fácil
então pra galera eu vou ensinar eles por
exemplo a como ah como criar os gpts vou
ensinar a galera a a como criar um clone
a seu próprio Então vou mostrar as
ferramentas que são de graça que vocês
podem já usar para depois pegar um gosto
e depois botar botar recurso né então A
ideia é realmente introduzir a galera
mostrar mostar Quais são os fundamentos
já também sim sim então vou fazer de uma
forma leve mas vai ser essa introdução
digamos assim e depois disso daí eu vou
abrir porque minha a minha comunidade eu
abri vagas para ela no passado e em
abril maio e nunca mais Abrir vagas
então só só pessoas integrantes poderiam
recomendar outras pessoas para entrar
por que que eu fiz isso pensando no
longo prazo eu prezei para criar uma
cultura lá dentro de abundância por isso
por causa do oito né o Infinito ou seja
eu quero que todo mundo pense abundância
Ou seja a gente isso é um benefício
muito grande que a gente tem no mundo de
a que é o quê você pode pensar Nossa
todo esse poder de a computacional se
caísse na mãos erradas poderia fazer um
estrago muito grande e realmente pode
acontecer ah criação de bio armas
criação de um monte de coisa que seria
muito errado só o que acontece por que
que eu fico feliz com com a forma como a
comunidade funciona as pessoas que são
mais bem motivadas que estão pensando de
uma forma digamos mais pura mais
positiva mais pelo bem comum o bem de
todos elas acabam muita
gente se juntando com elas sim e daí
acaba criando uma comunidade muito
grande e muita o que acontece por que
que nós humanos conquistamos tudo que
nós conquistamos Não é por causa da
nossa capacidade sei lá que a gente tem
só um dedo opositor ou que a gente tem
um ctex prefrontal at é porque dizem que
alguns Alguns hominídeos talvez fossem
até mais inteligentes do que nós mas nós
temos uma capacidade que lembra que eu
falei no comecinho que eu botei o gancho
pro final tinha uma coisa
mais mais importante que a capacidade de
imaginação exatamente É eu sei o que que
tu a falar agora agora já entregasse já
mas fala aí pro pessoal que é a nossa
capacidade de contar histórias ah merda
então errei ia falar capacidade de
cooperação a gente só consegue
compartilhar a gente só consegue
cooperar só porque a gente Coopera em
cima de histórias por exemplo dinheiro
dinheiro não existe sim é uma história
que dinheiro uma história dinheiro não
existe é um papel que não tem valor
nenhum na na na Venezuela estão pegando
lá milhões e limpando a bunda porque que
o papel dele o O dinheiro deles perdeu o
valor então o dinheiro em si ele não tem
valor o valor que tem a história que a
gente conta sobre o dinheiro que a gente
diz assim nossa o dólar é bem valorizado
né então assim o dinheiro país país não
existem não existe país é é uma é um
Delírio coletivo um país entre aspas né
tipo assim é um monte é uma crença
coletiva tipo assim aqui acabou Como
assim já tinha aquele rio a milhões de
anos e daí não aqui acabou aqui é Brasil
tipo não é um é a gente concorda com uma
com uma uma história que a gente conta
para nós mesmos religião é uma história
a gente vai ver tipo assim a gente
consegue se colaborar que realmente é a
colaboração humana em grande escala que
faz a gente ser mas por que que ela
acontece por causa do storytelling por
causa das histórias o que que passou ao
longo das Gerações a gente por muito
tempo a gente não teve a escrita mas por
milhares de anos a gente conseguiu
passar conhecimento como através da fala
através da do conto de histórias por
isso que uma vida lendária essa vida que
é tipo assim as pessoas ficam contando
contando contando a ponto chega lá no
futuro de uma forma Será que realmente
existiu Será que realmente o Alon
construiu a casa dele no braço no braço
í eu acho que ele construiu Essa é a cop
dele pelo menos tá a copia que ele manda
PR nós aí já vai fazer uns anos aí eu
tenho fotos é então tá elemento de prova
a também tem elemento de prova mas assim
é realmente a gente consegue colaborar
em conjunto porque a gente tem essa a
gente conta essas histórias por isso que
é tão importante tu contar histórias e
quando e é a mesma coisa a gente tá
contando várias histórias ali quando o
João vai lá e cria o Crew ai e fala F
cara eu quero poder potencializar isso
com as pessoas as pessoas se juntam com
ele quando o zuk lá o Mark Zuckerberg lá
da Meta ele pega e fala cara eu quero
transformar isso aqui de uma uma criar
uma Idi que é colaborativa que todo
mundo vai poder colaborar todo mundo
olha para ele e pensa assim [__] Cara
esse cara é massa eu vou fazer eu quero
usar esse negócio dele então as
histórias fazem com que a gente consiga
se entrar querer fazer parte das coisas
100% que tipo assim cara eu achei muito
interessante como a gente pode usar gpts
para criar Fer ferramentas
personalizadas criativas PR escalar
processo da tua empresa e daí que que eu
tirei que que eu tirei daqui tá que tipo
se tu é um empresário e tu entende os
processos chave da tua empresa [__] eu
sei que eu preciso eu sei cara se eu
fizer criativo é uma atividade muito
lucrativa para mim porque criativo dá
muito dinheiro então tu pode criar um
GPT para isso que vai te auxiliar em
partes específicas do criativo aí o que
eu entendi é que vale mais a pena criar
gpts isolados
Uhum que cada um Execute uma tarefa
específica porque a inteligência
artificial funciona melhor dessa maneira
uhum e não só isso como não não só
necessariamente Tu teria que fazer isso
no chat PT mas na ferramenta adequada
para aquilo que tu tá querendo fazer
então talvez copy não seja o chat PT
pode ser o o clou aí Aí talvez pra
imagem Seja algum outro pode ser Journey
por exemplo por exemplo assim Journey
agora versão se né ele consegue criar
rótulos em português como Esso aqui ah
perfeitos tu não precisa por exemplo tu
vai criar um um produto um produto
físico né sei lá um cosmético e tal tu
eu lembro que uma vez a gente contratou
para fazer estúdio não sei o que lá
tirar umas fotz cara tu não precisa mais
disso tu bota lá o rótulo que tu quer tu
escreve o que tu quer que tenha no
rótulo como é que vai ser ele vai criar
tudo e vai ficar perfeito tipo assim
perfeito não isso é muito top é é
perfeito tipo assim só que daí que que
eu eu uso eu criei um GPT que cria
prompts SP mid Journey Hum então eu
criei um GPT que cria prompt Journey por
que que eu tu criou um GPT que Journey
porque para eu não eu não quero ficar
decorando tipo assim Ah tem que ser luz
tem que ser a câmera sei lá Nikon 35 mm
para foto ser assim e e para porque tem
tudo isso isso aí no mid Journey eu eu
tô criando um GPT por exemplo que cria
ah prompts pro el Labs porque a galera
fala assim Nossa eu não gosto de El Labs
eu criei um udio lá não ficou igual o
meu Tu leu a documentação deles te
garanto que não porque se tivesse lido a
documentação deles tu ia ver que existe
formas de fazer prompts para Labs PR
fazer tu bota ali por exemplo aspas numa
coisa que tu escreveu daí ele grita tu
bota dois tracinhos ele fala baixinho
ele
susurra tu bota ali uma tag dizendo
assim ó quando eu falo ch é x ele vai
fazer então tu tu faz com que ele fale
do jeito que tu fala nossa que
interessante tu quer deixar ele por
exemplo falando manezinho ele vai falar
manezinho Ah isso eu duvido mano isso eu
duvido botar o Anderson ali falar com o
chat ali conseguir copiar o Anderson ali
cara o Anderson o Anderson é mano [__]
eu falei ontem eu falei ontem na aula da
minha formação falei pra galera assim
eles estav perguntando Ah mas dá fazer
isso dá fazer galera dá fazer tudo é tá
ô Olha só cara e o negócio de PT a gente
consegue automatizar tarefas importantes
então ó pessoal isso isso é importante
tá porque uma coisa que até o hormus
fala né que depois do que tem o negócio
aqui do meu nariz né que tu falou quem
não conhece o hormus pessoal um cara é
pô sensacional um [__] empreendedor aí
aprendi bastante com ele tem dois livros
que é o oferta 100 milhões de dólares e
leads de 100 milhões de dólares que ele
ensina a criar oferta a é quem não
conhece crii já um um clone dele GP Cri
um CL com todos os livros todos os
twitters deles todos os vídeos dele do
YouTube tudo Se alguém quiser conversar
eu posso botar aqui até na descrição
aqui do vídeo para conversar com ele Ah
é mas ele fala o seguinte que cara
depois que o empreendedor descobre
aquilo que ele vai fazer aquilo que dá
certo a primeira coisa que ele quer
fazer é merda é merda é parar de fazer é
ele ele fala [__] se eu subir um
criativo D dinheiro vou fazer então
outra coisa o que que eu vou fazer vou
rodar tiktok por qu porque eu fui no
evento e o Pedrinho tá rodando só que na
real não é assim Na real ele fala que
tem Framework né de do mais melhor e
depois o novo então quando acha uma
coisa que funciona primeiro faz mais
daquilo tenta fazer melhor daquilo então
pô subir um criativo sobe mais sobe
criativos melhores nessa fonte tráfego
aqui nessa única coisa só só depois tu
faz o novo então eu percebi que os gpts
eles como auxilia né nesse processo
criativo tu consegue fazer muito tu
consegue fazer mais e melhor rápido sim
Então cara pr pra gente pra galera que
trabalha com a gente aqui né tráfego
direto ou qualquer tipo de coisa que us
em mídia principalmente essas é esses
processos que exigem criatividade
produção de conteúdo tal eh conteúdos
Gerais tanto cop mais e tal daí isso é
muito interessante tu consegue fazer
muito mais com gpts isso isso eu entendi
isso achei muito valioso tá eu quero
tentar aplicar isso no vtb cara eu vou
ver como é que eu vou fazer isso ainda
para até tipo selecionar reels
automáticos tal coisas assim que eu não
peguei 100% e porém tu tu falou uma
coisa nas conversa tá que já falou faz
um tempinho tá sei lá uma meia hora aí
que tu falou só que agora tu até
repetindo né de do normous que tu falou
que tu consegue meio que clonar o o
cérebro e a aí conversar isso aí seria
um GPT próprio da pessoa ou seria uma
outra coisa ainda pode ser um G tu pode
fazer com GPT tu pode fazer isso com
Defy que é outra ferramenta pode fazer
com vários defi é o Defy é uma
ferramenta chinesa Olha que como eu tô
em contato com eles e eu sou o cara que
mais usa eu consegui fazer com que eles
traduzissem inclusive para português
Olha então consegui aí vários erros eu
achei lá na ferramenta eu falei para
eles e tal isso que é o legal dessa
comunidade é muito pequena igual cara é
2000 é o primeiro ano lá do afiliado do
Brasil sabe que tinha meia dúzia é isso
que é ia hoje tipo Tem meia dúa de gato
pingado que realmente sabe o que é ia
então é muito fácil de tu ter acesso a
grandes ferramentas a grandes pessoas
porque tem pouca gente então qualquer um
que se sobressai levanta o minguinho tem
se destaca que é o que eu tô o que eu
fiz tipo assim eu sou o cara que
levantou amiguinho eu não sou ninguém em
a só como ninguém todo mundo que tá
falando que sabe a não sabe a acaba que
eu me destaco sim e e esse a questão por
exemplo do do Clone e a basicamente é o
quê tu ter um local onde tu poderia
conversar com aquela pessoa e aquela que
que qual foi minha ideia né tu tu
conseguir fazer perguntas para aquela
pessoa digamos assim que que eu pensei
eu gosto muito de ler né pensei gostar
muito de ler Então a primeira coisa que
eu pensei foi vou subir todo o conteúdo
naval e vou conversar com o naval naval
foi o primeiro clone que eu querei e daí
eu subi todos os tweets dele todos todos
os artigos do site dele todas as
entrevistas dele e daí fui afinando a
voz dele ali né Tipo eu não fiz um fing
tunning no sentido da palavra técnica
que fing tunning na téc na parte técnica
treinar o maa Mas nem vou entrar nesse
nesse parâmetro que é muito mais
complexo eu afinei a voz dele no sentido
assim fui descobrindo quais tipos de
palavras ele fala e talo mais beleza
escrevi ali como é que é o estilo de
falar dele e e com base em todo o
conhecimento que tem ali dele essa Iá
pega eu Pergunta assim o que é
felicidade ela não vai escrever aquela
coisa assim ah felicidade é uma coisa
que que é muito sei lá é muito
individual de cada um não ela vai falar
já como fosse ele então vai pegar um
trecho do livro dele só que ela não vai
só copiar e colar com base na nossa
conversa com contextualização ela vai
contextualizar então é como se fos uma
conversa mesmo tem outra ferramenta que
agora eu esqueci o nome que eu tava
usando aqui para conversar eles estão
criando também específicos para Clones e
lá tu consegue conversar com todos os
filósofos que já existiram grandes então
tu liga faz uma ligação no celular e eu
fiquei não é aquele
Eh pai não tem um negócio desse tem mas
esse é bem fraquinho mas esse é legal
para brincar de graça mas esse não é
esse ele é pago e ele é bem legal que tu
liga eu fiquei por exemplo eu fiquei 48
minutos conversando com o jores jnes é
aquele do Aquele que tava lá no barrio
que tipo assim que que não tô ligado
esse aí ele é da época assim ele é ele é
e ele é meio que discípulo de do de um
cara que era discípulo de Platão um
pouco antes dos estóicos
então discípulo do cara que era
discípulo de Platão exatamente e assim
ele foi o Platão era o discípulo do
Sócrates
é é e esse cara ele inspirou o
estoicismo o então assim ah não era era
democritos democritos Ah tá é Dió eu
falei de dióis cara não demit o
Demócrito Tô ligado esse moleque é ele
ele é do é ele ele que que que que meio
que começou esse negócio cismo Essa é El
ele na verdade ele defendia outra coisa
que é o cinismo que é assim que ele é
ele defendia tipo assim cara a galera
para que que eu vou ter ter Terra ter
casa ter coisa assim sabe ele ficava
pelado meio da rua não tava nem aí sabe
ele era mendigo mas é um cara assim
super inteligente tanto que ele tem
vários relatos que tipo assim ele era
convidado para mostrar nas casas das
pessoas sabe pro medigo ser convidado
para mostrar na tua casa é porque ele
tem que ser [__] né sim e ele foi É no
mínimo tem tipo uma lenda né mas dita
por várias pessoas diferentes ao longo
da história que ele teve um diálogo com
com Alexandre o Grande que foi o
seguinte o Alexandre o Grande queria
saber quem era esse cara e tal daí ele
chegou lá com o general dele porque ele
sempre andava com os Generais e tal com
o pessoal do exército E perguntou para
ele o que que que tu queria e tal e o o
é jos não é dem dem democ lógo que era
eu acho que era jnis era Jó o do
estoicismo acho que que é demócratas Tá
mas eu não sei é o o estoicismo tem tem
vários né mas esse é o georis que ele
chegou lá e fez sombra no pro jores e o
jorn estava tomando o banho de sol lá lá
ele morava ele dormia dentro de um
barril e ele falou ó a única coisa que
eu quero é que tu ti tu tu saia do meu
sol sabe Claro ele falou de uma forma
muito mais filosófica do que isso mas
basicamente cara sai da frente aí tu não
tem nada para me dar e daí na conversa
dele acabou isso cara tu tu tá vazio tu
tá buscando o mundo porque tá vazio e eu
não quero nada tipo assim e daí nessa
nessa lenda Alexandre grande disse cara
se eu não fosse o Alexandre grande eu
gostaria de ser Diógenes porque é um
cara que tipo assim p o cara não precisa
de nada sabe e esse cara depois acabou
virando esqueci o nome do cara agora que
acabou criando o estoicismo depois que
ele o navio dele afundou lá que eu
esqueci o nome do cara não era o Zeno
Zeno zenão como é que se essa [__] Cara
Zen acho que é o Zeno é bom sei lá cara
lembro que tem esses aí daí tem o Marco
Aurélio o ceneca O Zeno epicteto e esses
Caraí Zen de city porque ele o barco
dele fundou ele era um mercante e daí
ele acabou ficando lá em Atenas e ficou
estudar e ele foi estudar o cinismo só
que ele viu cara cinismo não foi por que
que o cinismo chegando nos dias de hoje
sendo sendo sendo praticado e o
estoicismo sim agora uma febre né
Principalmente de 10 anos para cá porque
o cinismo dizia assim cara [__] vou
ficar sem nada nada tem se tipo e o
stoicismo não tipo assim tu pode ser
rico e sendo históricos cênica era um
dos caras mais ricos da época dele então
o estoicismo ele digamos ele ele é mais
democrático assim é mais fácil de ser
aceito pelas pessoas sim de fato é mas
eu conversei com por que que eu falei
isso né porque eu conversei durante 48
minutos com o geogen uhum por voz sabe
tipo assim trocando ideia sobre o
cinismo e foi interessante o cara foi
muito interessante muito profundo muito
muito muito as conversas vou te dizer
algumas das conversas mais profundas que
eu já tive foi com cloue ji porque ele
tem contextualização de 200.000 tokens
então a eu i conversando com ele sobre
algo extramente profundo ele ia
conseguindo se aprofundar com base nessa
conversa ao ponto de em um momento ele
começou a achar que ele tinha
consciência olha e daí até eu tenho
print disso porque tipo assim Opa posso
até e eu eu já buguei duas e as achando
que elas estavam vivas ou descobrindo
que estavam conscientes entre aspas
Porque assim vai chegar um momento que
ela vai gerar uma consciência que daí a
gente ID já vai ser próximo disso mas
principalmente aci que é que seria uma
super Inteligência Artificial isso daí
eu não ouvi falar a artificial cons é a
s i a s i a s e s i é que seria super
intelig super ar artifício super
inteligent faz sentido n que daí depois
que daí assim é algo que a gente não
consegue prever Tem gente que fala que
vai acontecer até 2040 2045 que é assim
ela vai ser tão rápido já tá acontecendo
ah a gente já tá conseguindo ter
descoberta de curso de de de de câncer
já foi criado já nanorobôs com células
que conseguem e destruir Câncer em
alguns lugares Ah é então tipo assim tá
tá sendo muito rápido esse ano vai ser
um ano que a gente vai descobrir e um
monte de medicamentos para doenças
extremamente raras porque por que que é
tão caro tu descobrir medicamentos para
doenças raras porque é um monte de
pesquisa dinheiro para uma coisa que tá
atingindo poucas pessoas a farmácia não
que a indústria farmacutica mas tipo
assim é um Business os caras não vão
botar dinheiro em algo que é para poucas
pessoas sendo que eles têm que atingir
várias mas a ia ela consegue descobrir
compostos torna viável então assim a
gente tá a gente tá entrando numa érea
de extrema prosperidade de extrema
longevidade só que ao mesmo tempo também
numa era onde a gente vai ter o maior
número de pessoas que são não
empregáveis e esse é o maior medo por
isso que falando assim H musk A galera
falou parem asias vamos lá vamos vamos
se juntar e vamos parar tudo isso aí por
que que eles se ligaram que assim a
gente vai ter o ival harar falar muito
sobre isso desde do homo Deus lá que a
gente vai ter cerca de 80% ou mais das
pessoas sendo pessoas que são não
empregáveis o que que é uma pessoa que é
não empregável é praticamente uma pessoa
inútil economicamente uma pessoa que
tipo assim ela não vai se adaptar tão
rápido quant as coisas estão mudando e
não vai ter trabalho para ela não tem
como tipo assim se tu dar o trabalho
para ela tipo tu dar aquele controle
despulgar V game para pro teu sobrinho
Para ele achar que tá jogando Sabe sim
sei se criarem vai ser um negócio assim
deixa ele achar que tá fazendo alguma
coisa Uhum mas não não tá fazendo por
quê Porque a ia tá sendo tá cada vez
sendo muito mais rápido e a cada cerca
de seis meses a gente consegue dobrar
isso Lomas que falou ontem numa
entrevista que ele deu a cerca a cada
seis meses a gente tá dobrando a nossa
velocidade Então tá sendo algo absurdo
tá tá indo muito mais do que aquela a
lei de não é de Murphy a lei de lembra
do da de dobrar os capões
capacidade de processamento a cada tanto
tempo Acho 18 meses que a gente consegue
dobrar a capacidade de processamento
porque a gente diminui eu achei que era
isso que el estava falando é outra coisa
então é outra coisa tipo assim não é que
a gente não tem uma lei para isso para
falar sobre ia porque é muito rápido mas
ele tá falando cara a cada seis meses a
gente já tá tipo assim tá absurdo a
gente tá conseguindo tipo dobrar
triplicar a velocidade de Por exemplo
essa faz com que a gente consiga
diminuir um transistor a cada 18 meses
então tipo a gente tá no momento agora
com chips de 9 nanômetros que fazem com
que as ias consigam ter e essa
velocidade absurda só que por exemplo a
China não consegue ter acesso a isso
porque os Estados Unidos tá bloqueando
Taiwan então a gente tá em beira de uma
guerra mundial por conta de chips entre
aspas porque quem dominar primeiro Adi
domina o mundo é por isso que os Estados
Unidos até Tá incentivando essas
empresas lá de dentro para que isso
aconteça e o Brasil atrasado assim com a
Europa atrasada eles impedindo que isso
aconteça nosso negócio é jogar bola
mesmo pessoal o podcast turb aí é o que
tem mas a galera só para para o pessoal
não ficar assim apavorado antes a gente
concluir Ah não então vai acabar os
empregos sim boa parte dos empregos vão
deixar de existir e não vai ser criado
empregos à medida que são destruídos os
empregos e isso vai exigir que a gente
tenha algum alguma ação social de
sustentabilidade para essas pessoas que
é uma coisa que foi já já falado há
muito tempo que é o base income né
aquela renda básica Universal bi só que
a galera tá falando o seguinte o mus tá
falou recentemente isso e mudou minha
visão como a gente vai ter muita
produtividade diferente da pandemia não
vai ter um base income tu vai ter um
High income porque vai ter produzindo
muuito então tu tem que aumentar o
número também tu vai ter muita oferta
para te aumentar a procura joga mais
dinheiro pra galera e por que que a
economia vai sustentar isso porque tem
muita produtividade então tu vai poder
ter salários de 2 3.000 aqui no Brasil
sem fazer [__] nenhuma simplesmente
porque tu é humano então o ser humano
vai te dar direito a ter uma renda alta
Universal Isso vai acontecer então as
pessoas não precisam se preocupar que
não vão ficar sem dinheiro mas elas vão
vão não vão ter mais propósito e da a
gente vai entrar numa numa grande
digamos assim onda de pessoas
extremamente depressivas e tudo mais
gente entra um pouquinho mais pra
distopia do negócio mas aí daria outro
podcast sobre isso e acho que a gente já
ficou bastante tempo conversando aqui é
bom
eh bom mas a gente tá praticamente acho
que 2 horas 40 45 aí cara
eh bom cara acho que é isso na real vou
vou B Será que tá vou te fazer uma
última pergunta tá que eu só tô
curiosidade sobre isso a utilidade então
da gente clonar o cérebro de alguém
fazer ali o esse negócio seria tu
conversar seria meio que tu facilitar o
acesso o conhecimento daquela pessoa
exatamente por isso que eu tô chamando
de GPT Expert que é tipo assim tu cria
um GPT que tu quer conselho por exemplo
eu eu já troquei muita ideia por exemplo
com o capil gupta e é muito legal
conversar com ele porque ele vai te dar
a resposta como se fosse conversando com
ele mesmo Sim Ah tu pode conversar com o
naval tu pode conversar com o Alex
hormos o primeiro eu criei o segundo
clone que eu criei Foi o Alex hormos eu
criei primeiro naval depois Alex hormos
porque eu queria entender algumas coisas
Ah é perfeito não tipo assim não vai ser
100% igual a aquela pessoa mas eu diria
que assim Uns 90 igual aquela pessoa
porque com base na em todas as
comunicações que existe ali da pessoa
e tu pergunta uma coisa ela vai buscar
na base de dados e vai responder similar
o que aquela pessoa responderia só que
com base no contexto que tu deu então tu
pode pedir dica de marketing para Alex
horos ou dica sobre felicidade dinheiro
com naval Sim cara muito interessante e
mano pô a gente conversou Pra [__]
aqui obrigado por esclarecer as coisas
aí tive muitas ideias muitos Loops
abertos acho que o pessoal que tá em
casa também deve ter dado uma fritadinha
na cabeça é uma coisa muito nova né
muito nova e daí é surreal cara eu eu eu
tô realmente
muito ansioso assim para ver o que que
vai acontecer porque é muito doido cara
se tu for sei lá tipo a gente né Eh
pensa nuns 20 anos atrás aí não uns 15
anos atrás tu deveria ter ali o seu sei
lá 17 18 Uhum aí era um mundo
completamente diferente né e mal tinha
acho que tinha smartphone né só que acho
que eu não tinha não lembro é acho que
18 anos atrás acho que não é tinha tinha
tinha É acho que deveria até foi 2008 né
é mas assim mas eu lembro que [__] Eu
lembro que os meus amiguinhos me
chamavam lá em casa ô João vamos brincar
daí a gente ia na rua jogar peão
entendeu jogar taco daí hoje em dia p a
gente consegue conversar com um robô
sabe isso é muito surreal e daí é eu
tenho assim por exemplo o que que eu já
tá acontecendo né Eu tenho esse óculos
aqui que ele é ele tem tem Iá também eu
consigo conversar já com iá eu tenho
também o meta 3 o Quest 3 que é o o
óculos que tu bota de realidade virtual
aumentada onde eu jogo por exemplo lá
com o Henrique Carvalho jogo com a
galera o Douglas Souza a galera do mar
digital a gente joga t goleiro a gente
vai a gente joga normalmente sexta sexta
à noite a gente joga Ah é ô me chama
então para jogar com vocês eu tenho eu
tenho eu tenho um lado óculos Quest Ach
Ah então vamos tipo assim é do Facebook
lá é a gente joga aqueles de cair do do
cé que é o o o population One que é tipo
de cair do C cara mas sabe que vocês
estão fodidos né Eu acho que porque o
que que vai acontecer Alan vocês vão
tomar um
pau gente tá jogando colaborativo Ah é
então vocês vão ganhar Então agora vocês
feram uma boa contratação contrataram o
Neymar aí do jogo mas aí que tá tá tudo
mudando realmente muito rápido a forma
como a gente tá usando isso aqui por
exemplo celular é uma coisa que
rapidamente vai ficar ultrapassada já
foi lançado semana passada o Rabbit que
é um dispositivo desse tamanhozinho
assim que tu bota no bolso e faz com que
tu consiga ter uma ya ali mesmo offline
e ter fazer e tipo assim que acontece
hoje a gente a gente isso é muito louco
que tá acontecendo porque tipo assim
eles estão chamando de llm os que é o
quê tu não vai precisar mais ter
aplicativos no celular porque aplicativo
é um saco aplicativo disso daquilo
daquilo daquilo outro não nem sasto tudo
que tu quer vai ser criado em tempo real
então tu quer ah eu preciso sei lá
comprar uma passagem então é criado um
aplicativo para ti em tempo real que vai
lá e vai buscar via api as informações e
vai comprar tua passagem e de ele pode
deixar de existir sim já já existiu Rick
and mory [__] várias vezes Mr mic sei
vai ser isso aí tu vai apertar o botão
Mr
mtic vejam essa série pessoal série
Melhor série que tem ele vai vai ter o
Mr mic eu confio muito nisso é ele vai
fazer todas suas coisas cara e que isso
já tá acontecendo a gente já vive no
futuro porquea a gente só sabe percebeu
isso ele não tá distribuído igualmente
mas ele exist exe Esse negócio é muito
real né porque tipo o celular ele é uma
user Interface para tu acessar as apis
sim só que se tu tem um um llm onde tu
fala ah faz tal coisa ele poderia
acessar para ti tudo isso daí entendeu
então tipo nunca não vai ter tipo aperta
esse botão tipo ah vtube tem que apertar
o botão para subir o vídeo botão para
configurar não tu fala assim cara ó meu
vídeo é esse aqui e tal eu quero que tu
suba ele aí e me me dá o código aqui tem
que ter isso isso isso o cara vai lá e
retorna para ti porque essa vai ser a
interface e cara é muito D tem tem uma
tem uma ferramentas que é assim hoje em
dia que tu só conversa com sim
o que un SAS que são assim sabe de
criação de de ebook ele já faz tudo para
ti tudo certinho então é vai ser isso
cada vez mais muito doido é a gente tem
que ver vai ter que também se atualizar
para ser cada vez mais Pois é eu tô
louco é Mas enfim vamos vamos com calma
aí tem muita coisa a fazer também já tá
um rolo assim imagina já tá rolo Imagina
mas cara muito obrigado por ter
comparecido aqui é o podcast Espero que
tenha gostado achas que passou rápido
passou passou passou rápido né A gente
vai conversando do nada é e Cara eu tô
surreal pô Olha só o Alan eu tomei duas
garrafas de água esse vagabundo aqui ele
falou umas quatro vezes mais que eu é o
bicho tomou a gente vai brigar comigo de
um golinho um golinho de água um
negocinho aqui tomou 20 ml é e cara é
obrigado por você ter dado um pouco do
teu tempo aí é para quem não sabe
pessoal O Alan ele
eh ele tá ele tá com esse negócio da
formação ia aí daí eh eu vou eu vou
soltar o teu podcast em tempo PR as
pessoas saberem isso para caso eles
querem sei lá consumir um pouco o teu
conteúdo vai ser que dia mesmo é dia 4
dia 29 eu começo a fazer as lives no You
dia 29 ó dia 29 de Janeiro tá pessoal
então esse podcast eu vou tentar hoje é
dia 19 eu vou tentar eu vou liberar ele
antes do do evento do do dia que é para
ser aqui do do evento para vocês daí e
conseguirem ter tempo aí e tal de de ver
consumir e tal conhecer mais sobre o que
ele tá fazendo e daí vamos lá tá pessoal
eu vou deixar o Instagram do Alan aqui
na tela fala o teu Instagram aí pro
pessoal o Instagram é @o Alan Nicolas
com n só @o Alan Nicolas com1 n só vai
aparecer aqui na tela tá pessoal então
se vocês gostaram do podcast compartilha
aqui embaixo eh O que que vocês acharam
legal se não gostaram fala também pra
gente poder melhorar e obrigado por você
D esse tempo aí pra gente tá é bastante
tempo os podcasts aqui são longos mesmo
mas cara é isso daí tá a gente tem
testra aí o máximo aqui do convidado
para passar bastante conhecimento para
vocês e cara eh enfim é isso aí Alan
deixa uma última mensagem pra galera aí
manda um abraço aí para ele sei lá então
primeiro deixa agradecer aqui pela
oportunidade eu achei que não não queria
mais aqui né porque eu falara João Ei
João não vai me convidar não calma calma
calma aqui V ch convi convidou então
obrigado por pela oportunidade também de
estar aqui trocando essa ideia contigo ã
agradecer a galera também por ter ficado
até o final aqui porque eu sei que a
gente passou por uns momentos aqui mais
difíceis de entender né mas é assim é
normal é faz parte e bom se você não
quiser ficar aí para trás se você não
quiser ser substituído rapidamente por
eu acho bom você atualizar isso aí então
pessoal Valeu mais uma vez Instagram do
al na tela Segue o al no Instagram segue
lá YouTube no Instagram gostou do
podcast compartilha com alguém e valeu